[Music]
my name is carlson he's been on fire
so far in the magnus carlson
invitational but we do know it is on
these crucial
second days in the knockout stage that
he has struggled before
so definitely we could be in for a
dramatic but also fun day
as support finals will be decided
welcome to the mouthwater champions
chess tour
[Music]
some chocolates young there good times
be careful
hello
[Music]
maybe we will see some anger today it is
one of these eight players that will be
the winner of the magnus carlsen
invitational
today four will be knocked out and four
will go through
to the semi-finals and to guide us
through all the excitement today
women's grandmaster ivanka houska and
grandmaster david howell and david
magnus carlson he was on fire yesterday
seemed unbeatable but what do you expect
from him
on this day too it's hard to bet against
magnus he looked in
imperious form back to his best for sure
magnus
he has struggled in the past but this
time it feels like something's different
it feels like he has
found that consistency it is four
quarter final matches that we are
looking at ivanka where are you
expecting the most drama today
well it has to be on those matches where
the scores are tied and i'm especially
excited about the match between hikara
nakamura
and yana pomniacci because both these
players have very aggressive style
and uncompromising attitude and you know
i have a feeling that they're going to
want to
bring it on and in fact i do have
access to hikaru nakamura's tweet and
earlier on the day
he did tweet just another day at the
office and you can see
he is channeling dwight schrute
bring it on
you like the office don't you david yeah
i prefer the uk version of the office
i don't know i know many people and
actually the uh actor of dwight
rayne wilson king chess play himself all
right well it's gonna be a very fun day
at the office an exciting day let's take
a look at today's schedule and we will
start
to follow the first game between nepo
and nakamura they are tied after
day one a lot of exciting chats and
maybe we will have tie breaks after
the fourth round but we are also going
to join by international master lawrence
trent later on
and we will talk about what happened
when magnus carlsen
became a grandmaster at 13 years old we
will get to know
this story after the first game today
i still very much remember the the
nervousness that i felt
felt on the day and the game where i
finally got the title and
my opponent i think offered a draw in in
a somewhat worse position and
frankly i mean i couldn't have uh could
not have taken the draw any faster
because
i just wanted uh one of the titles
definitely is a prestigious club to be
part of grand masters all of these
hr grandmasters david you are one
yourself
do you remember that day very well um
the day i became a grandmother
yes it was actually not too far away it
was in sweden in stockholm and
i was a bit like magnus i secured the
title with a draw in the last round
and ivanka women's grandmaster is such a
big title as well and it is
big achievements that we are talking
about in the quiz of the day as well
yeah we are doing that but everyone not
everyone can
be a grandmother at chess you know let's
face it
let's face it um but we are asking the
question what skills do you have
or maybe even aspire to have that are
grand
master level and you can tweet your
answers using the hashtag
chess champs tweet us your pictures your
thoughts absolutely anything
it's gonna be a lot of fun and one lucky
winner
wins an air things mini device which we
have
sitting on our table all right
i'm gonna follow that today now
grandmaster magnus carlson he was
fantastic in the preliminaries won that
overall
and in the first day of quarter finals
against levon aronian
the world champion seemed almost
unbeatable
he's been playing such brilliant amazing
chats out of this world on the first day
of the quarterfinals of the magnus
carlson invitational
magnus started energetically and
outplayed lavon aronian in
powerful style levon fighting trying his
best to make it difficult
levon aurora is still fighting he's such
a lion long term he's losing he just
resigns
yes he's seen enough wow so he does
resign here
on naronia and what a start ivanka from
minus carlson to the coach vinyl
in his second game against the armenian
lion magnus was hungry for more
now we will see what magnus carson has
in store
as well as his noodles that we see him
tuck into no
not again second day in a row
okay a slightly surprising move by levon
aronian um aronia has just taken the
time out to shuffle his king to the
corner but
um why rooney's about to lose a piece he
just resigns
about to go down on material what he did
in the
in the opening in the second game was
white
it was ambitious but it didn't didn't
really work
at all it's been a pretty consistent
theme
i feel uh at least in the in the last
tournament
and and this that i play well on the
first day
i mean i think my my win rate in as
white in the first game must be
must be pretty much pretty high the
americans had mixed experiences today
wesley so won his first match of the
quarterfinals
whilst hikaru nakamura drew in a titanic
struggle against the russian
janna pomniacci not easy to find maybe
you're not a for a human i think this is
very difficult to find okay he doesn't
find it if he pushed this pawn forward
black is stuck and white is winning the
game
i mean this is the first critical
position you mentioned right jan where
yeah just here i mean something like a4
and he's like
once he played a5 there is no no
defending ideas for black and the force
i mean sooner or later he'll get into
swan so when he moves i make his bishop
i just play bishop e1 and he resigns
so this is like uh what i would do like
probably 99 games out of 100 but yeah
today was
a slightly different thing
he did have a good day but he seemed so
disappointed david
yeah and rightly so um it's more of a
case of missed opportunities for
napoleon yesterday he could
and should have beaten nakamura in their
head-to-head match
but okay they're on level footing
heading in today into today
and if napoleon actually plays like he
did yesterday he must be the favorite
so let's take a look at the the results
from the first
matches in the quarter finals we do know
they played two
matches so magnus carlsen he was
unbeatable and he did
win the court final against the first
match against lebanon after only three
games same
situation for wesley so after only three
games he was the winner
against ali reza russia but we do see a
lot of drama happening
between hikaru nakamura and jana pognaci
and also between anishigiri and
maxim vajayla grab so before the second
day of court funds these are the
standings
magnus crossland and wesley so both up
by one point
it is tied in the two other
quarter-final
matches and levon aronian he struggled
so much yesterday uh i mean
it's almost like he's got nothing to
lose today i guess he just needs to be
better
yeah he's in survival mode you know if
he wants to stay in the competition he
needs to start winning unfortunately his
opponent is none other than the boss
world champion magnus carlson but lavon
aronian did give
us an insight into his mindset he did
say he did tweet
played badly uh badly yesterday but
there is still a chance as
bill russell now this is an american
basketball player
once said before a very tough game seven
it has been done
before so uh this is definitely actually
a basketball player
from earlier times ah well if he's able
to
win this second match against magnus
carlsen then in that one we will head
into tie breaks and
what does that mean david that's right
tie breaks um
we will decide in blitz and armageddon
chest
time will be slashed um in the blitz
best of two games
each side will only have five minutes on
the clock getting only three seconds
after every move
if after those two games we still cannot
find a winner then it's armageddon white
will have five minutes black will have
four minutes but white
has to win to progress to the to the
semi-finals all right well
for yana pomnyachi it quite possibly can
end up
in thai breaks he is tied with hikaru
nakamura after
the first day and all the drama today
will of course as always
take place in the player's home such as
his online chess so let's
uh take a look at where yana pognachi
lives in moscow
[Music]
that's not the most crowded place i
would say
but i like it here we see the doggo
and also football and basketball peach
too much snow
jogger he doesn't want to go
he's too independent
my center so we actually moved here like
two years ago this is the bedroom and
rishi our cat
[Music]
okay let's get going yeah
this is the kitchen and actually
the tea i really like the living room
beautiful hogwarts stuff
some dudes probably from from norway
another dude the fridge
you know is not particularly great but i
haven't been here for quite some time
and just came
to play the event from from this place
here is a guest room the camera to
record what's going on
during uh events streaming setup and
stuff
yeah dude
i really like razer stuff when you share
in world of warcraft style
tv and it was playstation here it was
before
so some books this is for me to run
so guys thank you for watching and see
you during
chess champions tour so nice of jana
pognyarchy to let us into his homes and
uh well i noticed a lot of dudes
[Laughter]
certainly um maybe he's a big fan of the
big lebowski
the dude abides i can't help myself
there
yeah i mean when when you have those
little supporters cheering you on you
can't go wrong can you yeah exactly
that's what he needs then
well um maybe he also needs to be feel
powerful david and that
chair yeah an impressive chair um
napomiacci is actually famous as a bit
of an
all-around gamer he plays world of
warcraft he plays a game called
hearthstone
very well he's actually commentated at
elite level in hearthstone so
yeah he takes all of these games very
seriously all right well he's fantastic
and chess as well living in moscow let's
head into
the play zone clock is taking down
towards the first
round of today and we do know jana
pognati he is living in
moscow it's almost seven o'clock for him
uh but levonaronian it's even later for
him in armenia
eight o'clock maximum vagina grab in uh
paris famous otherwise
yeah it's five o'clock same for magnus
carlson and anish geary and those
americans
early in the day for them so who's
feeling the most fresh going into today
do you think ivanka
well definitely i think it will be very
much
the europeans especially ali reza
farouja anish giri who are playing at
5pm magnus castle of course playing at 5
p.m
in the evening it's a slightly tougher
for la borna ronin and javiana pomniacci
and i think it's every chess player's
nightmare
to be playing early in the morning like
hikari nakamura is
and uh yeah but of course they have to
put those time considerations to the
side because it's all
going to be about the chess it's all
going to be about the chess and who goes
through to the semi-finals and i do know
chess24 did another poll about this they
did they did
uh and they produced a poll yesterday
the verdict was that 90 percent believed
that magnus would win against levon
aronian today
it is 93 in magnus's favor and
the same goes for hikaru nakamura
actually his has decreased it's gone
down one percent
now 31 percent of people think that
nepal napolniacci is going to
win and when it comes to wesley
instagram users don't believe that ali
reza
will actually make a comeback he his
odds have gone down to 20
and when it comes to anish giri well
actually his has decreased
he has uh well only 75 percent of people
think that he will now
take the victory against maxine bachelor
well i do
agree with the viewers anything can
happen anyone can still qualify
for the semifinals let's take a look at
the match-ups before the first game
in on the second day of quarter-finals
so lavon aronian
he needs to strike back he lost the
first day against the magnus carlsen
and then we do have already russia same
situation for him he lost the first day
he needs to strike back
against the great wesley so today
for maximum vagielagrav and anish geary
it is all tied after that first
day david and who do you have as a
favorite here i think this is actually
the closest match right now
um it was well it did end 2-2 yesterday
both sides had their chances both sides
up and down i would say anisha is the
slight favorite because he was more
impressive in the preliminary stage but
bachelor graf is a tricky customer but
the one that we will follow in this
first game it is
the first game between yon pomnyachi and
hikaru nakamura
they tied the first day but
david you were saying that you did feel
that ianna pognachi
were the better player yesterday yeah i
think he was more impressive
of the two players his only loss janna
pogiacci came in the first game
but after that he really dictated the
play he had the chances he could easily
have won actually 3-1 yesterday
and the pogba actually if he hadn't let
some chances slip
nakamura needs to just be better than he
was and look at that he's getting ready
ivanka what do you expect from napo here
with the white pieces important in the
first game
yeah i mean one thing that was very
interesting about yesterday's match is
that
nepo actually dipped into his secret bag
of trips for the tricks for the
candidates
and came up with a fantastic opening
what we call which has been an idea that
never been seen before
and it completely blew hikaru nakamura
away
so i'm expecting a little bit more of
those the same thing
actually i think why not yeah and we do
yeah we do see an opening this time it's
the italian game yesterday in the
ponyachi had a lot of success with white
in the spanish opening this time similar
but slightly different
we don't see a berlin end game today so
this one
is more tense both sides just developing
the pieces both sides of castle now
um it's about maneuvering white bringing
his knight towards the center
very very tense all the pieces all the
pawns still on the board and see that
last move by white this is
a very typical idea you bring the knight
back you put put both of your knights
near the white king it means the white
king is super safe it means
once your pieces are developed it's time
to push forward in the center and
i've seen this position countless times
both of these players are very familiar
with the ideas as well
it's already move 11 but the players
they i mean i'm
i wouldn't be surprised if they continue
playing super quickly until move 20 and
beyond
because this is so well known this is
very popular especially at the top
levels
um nakamura is maybe the leading expert
from the black side he's defended this
against magnus carlsen against
a level neroni and against plenty of uh
opponents so is the question now who can
bring up the first
surprise in the game and being the one
with the white pieces do you think
janupomnyachi
will have a plan here of some sort
noponyyachi especially with white in
recent years he's become an opening
expert
and um i think i mean nakamura is the
one who's predictable nakamura is the
one who repeats this
day in day out he goes for this opening
all the time so napoli actually he will
be aiming
um to launch the first surprise but yeah
it's just about homework who has done
the better homework
whose coaches have helped them the best
exactly exactly
you kind of summed it up beautifully
that david in my database here i can see
that it is vascular graph versus hikara
nakamura grishik has tried his luck
against hikaru
then maxim again and dingleran and
finally the big boss himself magnus
carlsen
you know he nakamura has played this
this position
many many many times and uh what's his
score like ivanka
okay i will check his score his i will
expand that a little bit
yeah i mean nakamura he is the leading
expert from the black side of this
opening so anyone
who wants to learn how to fight against
the italian game from the black side
one of the most popular openings in
chess check out nakamura's games
um i'm slightly surprised naka is
thinking here maybe he's just trying to
remember something
normally he looks off to the left when
he's trying to recall ideas here he's
looking down
i think it's just similar he's very
familiar i mean he's had this as ivanka
mentions
against all the top players in the world
and um eventually he comes up with a
move
he challenges the opponent's knight so
he's lost he's kind of mainly drawn but
he's actually lost two games in this
variation
and uh one one so he beats uh
i think it was i guess he beat maxine no
grishik alexander grishik
in this exact position in this exact
position okay so nothing new under the
sun
so far um janna probably actually he's
built up an extra
two minutes and 20 seconds with the
speed uh
which he's been playing look at the
pontiac's face
he is not he's not impressed by
nakamura's last move
he's surprised to say the least um and
he's not afraid of showing his uh
surprise
um i'm slightly confused as well i
thought there was another move that was
a bit more popular no i mean
actually actually this pawn sacrifice is
the first time
now it's ever been seen so now it's
hikaru that has dipped into his magic
bag
and come up with a new idea to the
position because
every single other game had involved
black basically capturing the white
knight
and here we have a sacrifice yeah so if
we bring up the analysis board because
there's been a lot of action so far
it was very tense and then nakamura's
last move has been to push the pawn
forward
trying to hit upon white's weakness in
the center this pawn currently a bit
weak
you cannot actually capture it right now
there's a really nice trick in the
position if black gets greedy and tries
to recapture the pawn that he's down
then knight takes pawn and a series of
traits knight takes
bishop takes and now this type of tactic
comes up all the time so
players at home if you're just learning
chess always look out for discovered
attacks
here white would play rook takes bishop
luring out the enemy's queen
and suddenly there's a bit of tension
along this line and white can clear the
line
by giving check attacking the black king
gaining time
and clearing the way to win the black
queen
that is why nakamura didn't get greedy
in the end and
in this position he decided not to
capture this pawn and not to play
the move i was expecting to bring his
bishop into the middle of the board to
attack this rook
instead pushing a pawn so now napoli
actually has a choice
um i would be tempted to just capture
this pawn and in this position
everything's equal apart from white
having an extra pawn
it's not the most important pawn right
now it's not the most impressive pawn it
is nicely blockaded by black's bishop
but
a pawn is a pawn and it could become a
factor in the end game
surprising stuff by nakamura but he's
confident of defending this one
because black's pieces are relatively
active
all right well i have to say that you
did uh
uh proceed david around move 20
yes is when they would start slowing
down and they definitely have they
definitely have and it's all to do with
that last move
um i wonder if i just wonder if nakamura
is slightly bluffing
whether he's studied this beforehand um
napoli actually was certainly surprised
by that last one i must admit myself i
spent
several hours studying the last position
but i'd never looked at this porn move
um for black so maybe it was similar
with napomniachi
um often the grand masters sometimes
we get i mean we forget to go back to
basics we get a bit carried away when we
study with a computer we only look at
the top computer suggestion
or the second computer suggestion
sometimes um the opponent has a
perfectly viable move but it might be
the third or fourth suggestion
and just because you know we're lazy
as humans uh uh we get complacent we
just forget to look at
um kind of very logical moves and okay
in the end
napoli actually decides to just move his
queen can it sometimes be frustrated
ivanka i
i think i would feel frustrated
sometimes that there are so many
possibilities
in chess and so many positions and
looking at an opening and then you feel
in control of
maybe if he does that move but then it's
like a thousand other moves
that you have to study as well yeah i
mean it can feel
overwhelming at times especially when it
comes to memorizing all sorts of things
but uh
what kind of gets you through it is like
the pattern recognition
and often you can quickly judge whether
position is very sharp or not
um usually that's kind of determined by
king safety
or whether there's a lot of tension on
the board and
the annoying thing is and it happens
often quite
a lot is when you're obsessed with
looking at things on the computer and
when you actually get to a physical
board
you kind of go what happens if my
opponent does that no i didn't i didn't
look at that in my nose
and then lo and behold your opponent
makes that move and you're like you're
thinking
hmm but uh okay and then you're on your
own
exactly yeah i mean you're totally on
your own but i mean here
i think this kind of all came about
because um napomniachi simply assumed
that hikora was going to carry on
playing in the same way that he's been
playing before
um and every single trend in the in the
previous positions had been
you just capture the white knight
continue the game
and uh here we have a completely
different situation because
you can actually see the position is
really sharp and it's sharp because
white has this rook in the center of the
board
which may or may not be a good piece
that's uh
we don't know that yet and uh every
single one of black's pieces
are really active and when you have a
situation like that
every move counts and this is why you
see napomniacci he's actually
played an attacking move he's moved his
rook to the side and is attacking the
knight and
he's trying to maximize every piece on
the board
and that's the only way that you can
play this position you can't make
waiting moves you can't just go oh let
me tidy up my pawn structure no
it has to be all about the pieces yeah
we often hear
these uh these really top ground masters
talk about the word tempo
and if you can make a useful move while
gaining time
while creating a threat while kicking
your pieces uh you're kicking your
opponent's pieces back
then um that's usually the ideal move so
yep uh
nice idea here from the pontiac black's
knight under attack twice
it has to move pretty much um yes it
could be defended by a pawn but you
don't really want to weaken the black
king right now so i expect to see
nakamura not spend too much time
just retreat the black knight and
napomiacci
if you look at the white pieces they're
nicely centralized all he needs to do is
activate his pieces in the corner
if you activate that rook in the bottom
left corner then um
white's position looks pretty nice um i
i envisage somehow an attack brewing
against the black king
just because all of white's pieces it
just feels like they will start pointing
towards that king side in a moment my uh
my kind of like signpost as to when i
should attack on the king side
is actually determined by the white pawn
that you see
in the center i kind of have a rule when
the white pawn is there that's
basically an indicator that you should
go all in for attack against the king
now if the pawn were sitting on the
square next to it
opposite the black queen then that's a
completely different approach
there i kind of go into space monster
mode which is
basically take up absolutely everything
control
all the sides of the boards and uh yeah
so
hikaru has defended the knight with the
queen and he's connected the two rooks
so this looks like a great kind of
developing move
i mean but uh it wasn't popular i can
see by the bar that the bar did not like
that at all
yeah um some moves um it's very
mysterious why or why
i mean why the computer doesn't like it
or why it does like it for example but
here i
i trust the computer because to me that
looks like a very provocative move it
looks like it's asking white to come
forward
with the queen with the queen exactly
that's what i want to do you know
caveman chess you know line up the queen
and the bishop maybe we can show it
on on a board and uh yeah
bring your queen up line it towards this
diagonal um suddenly the black knight is
under attack
three times um from the rook the queen
and the bishop and
it's just overwhelmed you can't move
this knight um if you move it back
immediately checkmate and that ends the
game um
and if black can't move the knight then
there's only one other option you have
to defend it but suddenly the black king
is much weaker than it was
suddenly there are holes around it these
squares start to look
very ripe and very juicy for a piece for
a white piece later on
i could imagine for example a move that
our good friend simon williams gm would
suggest
pushing this pawn trying to start
undermining black's
king protection and suddenly all of
white's pieces are perfectly placed
and black is the one under pressure so i
expect to see this move uh pushing the
queen forward
by nepaliacci now okay
so the bar is liking the situation
for yon pomnyachi he did struggle
yesterday
we talked about that with sort of just
finding that final
push in some of the game so is this
going to be a similar situation do you
think
um i'm not so sure i i mean it feels
like the
type of position that he thrives in um
napoli actually he like i mean ever
since he's been young
um he likes these positions where he can
just slowly build up and apply the
pressure
where he can kind of play by instinct uh
rather than always having to calculate
everything out
of course he's great at calculating as
well but um he does like to be on the
front foot doing the attacking and
okay a slightly surprising move bringing
the knight across attacking black's
knight in a different way but offering a
trade
and um personally i would have preferred
pushing the queen forward but
i mean this one has its kind of benefit
pros and cons as i mean let's just say
because uh with a nitrate then suddenly
look at those
two laser-like white bishops just
cutting across the board you know
they're just the dream even the one
that's at home that looks like it's
doing
absolutely nothing um and
i do the more i look at it they're kind
of more i i do like it
yeah it's definitely an interesting move
by napoli actually
it's got some ideas behind it if we
bring up the board we can see black's
knight again
is the problem piece it's under attack
three times once more if
black plays the most natural move just
trading off these knights then as ivanka
mentions this bishop although it's at
home
it has a i mean there's probably quite a
big threat in the position
white intends to capture on this on this
square sacrifice this bishop
open up black's king and as you
mentioned these two bishops
they're perfectly placed and this is a
good sign that you're going to attack
yeah i do really like my uh chess
analogies and i i just love to describe
chess in very creative imaginative ways
um but uh yeah and if you compare this
black bishop as well look at this piece
just blocked in by its own pawn
um i think that that factor alone is
enough to show the white has the
advantage
yeah and i do have to show you you guys
that uh mr dodgy has in fact clipped
the moment when janna pomneyachi was
surprised by hikaru's novelty and there
you can see
look at that
and if you want to join in the farm the
conversation
you can tweet your answer using the
hashtag chess champs and as you can see
we just
absolutely adore having pictures so send
them all in
um yeah tweet us on chess champs yeah no
probably actually he's never had a poker
face
his whole career i mean that's one
difference between online and
over-the-board chess sometimes online
you don't see your opponent's face if
you don't have the webcam up
um but yeah over the board having played
the probably actually countless times i
can
i know it's i mean it's intimidating
when you play a move and suddenly he
kind of frowns
um i remember playing him once and i
played a series of good moves but every
move he was frowning and then eventually
i just blunted because i assumed that i
was losing
just from his face and uh oh no no no no
no that's the way
that's a way to get bluffed i mean that
happened to me um against the grand
master you know every move i made was he
was
gurning away i mean it was really
off-putting
and he he did a queen sacrifice and i
was like
this is not good but he was looking at
me kind of no
i thought better not to take it and then
it got kind of published in the
newspaper because of course i was
winning and it was like in a shocking
display and a shocking lack of
confidence ivanka
did not accept his queen sacrifice which
was appalling i was like
okay let my lesson just block them out
never trust the opponent
yeah pissed yourself and meanwhile
nakamura he is currently trusting the
pontiac he hasn't
taken those knights off the board um i'm
not sure what else black can do though
um you don't really want to retreat with
the black knight because we mentioned
this idea earlier white will just
shuffle the queen up the board
line up the queen and the light squared
bishop on the same diagonal there's some
huge threats coming
um so if i were nakamura here i would
just say okay there's nothing better to
do there's nothing else to do
just take those knights off the board
and then start to think
nakamura he's probably just looking two
or three moves ahead that's why he's
spending so long right now
it's um yeah difficult position and a
bit lower on the clock
yeah start today yeah it's kind of
hasn't worked out his idea of just
sacrificing the porn and
uh and trying to generate play i mean it
looked
in fact i must admit until um napolita's
rook moved where he put pressure on
black's knight it did look like black
was
getting a great position you know active
pieces fantastic
and uh suddenly within two moves
we have the makings of an attack yeah
and uh it's primarily to do with those
bishops actually those bishops that
white house is just
wow yeah out of this world yeah i mean
having studied this opening a lot this
this exact pawn strike structure is
typical um for this opening and
the one reason i don't like these
positions for black is uh
is because computers they often say it's
equal or roughly equal
but that doesn't mean that the position
is necessarily easy to play
or kind of balance to play for both
sides it's much easier to find plans for
white
as black you need to be super accurate
in order to defend and
i always hate those types of positions
computer says 0.0 or 0.2
nothing nothing significant but
um yeah often you have to find a series
of forced moves only moves in
in order to stay in the game and yeah
that's why nakamura is thinking right
now
i mean he he doesn't look too unhappy he
probably knows that black is fine if
he's accurate
but um yeah finding accurate moves in
this position
is not easy nakamura as well we should
mention he likes those
um i mean it was once described by
yasser sarawan i think those 80
90 type moves where it's good enough
it's not necessarily the best but it's
good enough and nakamura when he gets
those types of positions where he can
play moves that are good enough when he
can play them quickly
um he builds up some confidence he plays
on the opponent's nerves later on
that's how nakamura wins games but here
he needs to find those 100 type of moves
where it is the best
every time otherwise black is in big big
trouble
yeah oh as i mean it's a very difficult
position to play actually i mean
i mean yes i agree with you the computer
will probably say
nothing to worry about but the computer
has got no emotional element
it's not feeling things the same way
that hikaru is because hikaru for sure
before he captures that night he is
assessing the danger how can he handle
you know those pieces that are going to
be sacrificing themselves or coming
towards
his king and it's not an easy
job at all i mean
let's have a look at the let's let's do
a deep dive into the position david
let's have a look at what happens if
hikaru were just to go night takes night
cool as the houses yeah so these bishops
back in
yeah yeah back in the game back in the
game and i know and this is the problem
okay so white has a few ideas
one idea is to sacrifice the dark square
bishop
all the way out take that pawn remove
the king's cover because
opening up lines is basically the
currency for attack there is also
another threat in the position and we
touched upon it earlier
and that's simply to march the queen two
squares forward
line her up and well bob's your uncle as
we say in the uk
we certainly it's like the most random
expression there is
it's like oh look it's a done deal bob's
your uncle
we have a checkmate on the board it's
like oh
yeah yeah i mean that's a huge threat as
well i think what black needs to do in
order to make sure that bob
isn't yan's uncle uh is to drop the
bishop back
um black bishop should drop back
attacking this rook forcing this rook to
make a decision
it's actually not an easy decision uh
maybe the best square is to go up
but you do allow ideas such as this one
attacking the queen and attacking the
rook
this isn't such a big deal right now
because white still has this checkmating
threat
um of jumping into this square and the
king will be a target
but um yeah jan if he needs to put his
rook on a bit of an awkward square then
at least nakamura has chances maybe
he'll just shuffle his rook across and
hope to defend later on yeah i think
this is best but
it's not easy to play it's not easy to
allow white's pieces nearby and there's
still ideas such as bringing the bishop
forward bring the queen forward later
every single one of white's pieces is
going to join that attack and
nakamura on the back foot all right
i need to learn more of these english
what would that be idioms yeah
i mean we have a lot of strange ones
like uh i know
uh when i was working with yasser sarah
one he would he would say the one that
fascinated
him the most as an american was uh
he's got a lot of bottle
and that just basically means you've got
a lot of courage ah you've got a lot of
guts
yeah so if you bottle it that means you
kind of lose your courage and you
you kind of choke at the wrong moment
okay
yeah i'm famous for bottling it i don't
have enough bottle
um yeah so will nakamura show his bottle
in this game and capture that night
survive i mean it's looking bad for
nakamura that clock time
four minutes now left for the rest of
the game
napoli actually has three times as much
um on the clock
and not just is black's position
um really difficult to play difficult to
handle i mean that clock time when
you're on the defensive
um there's almost going to be no chance
nakamura he needs to speed up and he
needs to find a clear-cut solution
i think he's he's searching for
something a bit forcing a bit concrete
to immediately solve his problems but
you can't do that there's just no
solution
you need to just kind of hold tight just
be supe uh just
be steady and slowly uh block all the
threats
i think he's just panicking it is
seriously wrong i mean
i mean when you look at the clock times
like you said david napolita has
12 minutes hikaru has just over three
and a half i mean that is
very very significant and that's a huge
huge disadvantage
yeah i mean he's on the ropes already i
mean he has played the moves that david
wanted him to play which was to
just capture the knight and now we are
looking for a key move which is that the
black
square dar squared bishop needs to
retreat
needs to make a very very funny move
retreat and attack the rook otherwise
there are all
sorts of attacks happening in the
position yeah i mean this
just shows to me that nakamura he's not
really uh not feeling fresh not feeling
in the zone right now because
that last move it was pretty much forced
for black there was no other option
nakamura spent 10 minutes on it i mean
in a 15-minute game in total you can't
spend 10 minutes on one move
but not only that but he played the most
obvious move after all that time
but he didn't have a continuation uh
surely if you invest 10 minutes you have
an idea of how you'll continue
uh next napoli actually immediately
recapturing immediately replying and
nakamura back thinking again two and a
half minutes now
um bad position as well it's um
yeah i think it's already looking dire
for nakamura so bob
bob is hikari's uncle uh no bob bob will
be
the formula she's uncooked okay so it's
good to have bobas and uncle yes
oh okay yeah very but the expression
kind of means like oh
i'm surprised yeah okay as if by magic
that would be like a better translation
as if my magic
look checkmate is that what it means
yeah are you sure yeah
oh okay maybe i'm learning as well i'm
gonna give you a second
i find that we're like saying and saying
in different languages
there's always like different uh
interpretations of them
mm-hmm right yeah well i mean it was
difficult for me as a child actually
because
my parents are not from the uk they're
actually from uruguay
and uh you know they would never know
all these idioms and so i remember
looking at these tests and i was like
as cool as a ice cream of course and the
answer is of course cucumber
apparently it just means there it is
yeah it is as it's my magic done
is this by magic there it is your uncle
there it is
yeah and um look at that one minute now
for hikaru nakamura one and a half
minutes okay he does eventually retreat
the black bishop
napolniacci meanwhile was thinking in
nakamura's time
that's a very good practical tip um lots
of chess players
weak strong young old they spend i mean
when their opponent's thinking
they just lose concentration they start
thinking about other things they start
wandering around
but um yeah napoli actually was thinking
in nakamura's time and yeah nakamura has
gone for a controversial decision he's
decided to sacrifice the pawn
um is it enough ivanka white now a porn
up
look at that white rook it looks oddly
placed but it's pretty strong right now
it does look very very strong
and i do have to say it is almost like
uh we have a tweet from maya tingza aong
who says
he's so used to watching hikaru playing
online blitz quickly
that seeing him thinking for over five
minutes feels
strange i mean absolutely and i don't
like his decision
actually i mean just to give up a pawn
because now napomniachi
will be feeling super happy because he's
converted his initiative
his attack into something concrete which
is an extra pawn
yeah i mean now it's not just a kind of
theoretical advantage it's a tangible
advantage
um napoli actually he can win this game
in several ways now he can try and
hustle on the clock
he can try and use his extra pawn or he
can try and continue the attack
so um a lot of leeway here from the
pontiac and he does push
that corner pawn harry vh pawn he pushes
it up the board he's just trying to
undermine
the protection around black's king and
it's looking
very very good right now um nakamura i
think
it was a case of long think it's a wrong
think and
he gave up that pawn no immediate
compensation no real justification for
it
and dramatic on the clock i mean most
definitely yeah
hikaru is down 10 minutes on the clock
yeah and with a worse position do you
think there's any way he's going to be
able to save this david
i think it's he needs a miracle right
now um
yeah napoli actually he continues the
attack look at this white's pawn pushing
forward
um he should just be winning now
nepomniacci
okay there is a sneaky threat in the
position um nakamura has created a
threat if we bring up the analysis board
black has one idea here with this last
move bring the rook across
um if white gets careless and just for
example pushes a pawn then black will
play
rook takes bishop down here eliminating
the defender of this rook and suddenly
black will have won a piece that is why
napoli actually okay of course he'll see
this threat
of rook takes bishop he just shuffles
his bishop out of the way this rook is
on an open line but it's got no entry
squares it's not going anywhere
and napoli actually he's getting ready
to bring his final piece into the game
uh more importantly though he's going to
at some point just take this pawn
black's king is going to be too open
pawn up and a dominant
position and just to kind of reference
that kevin winter's tweet which is just
over there on the screen
and he's talking about good enough moves
and uh here i
this is like a prime example for me yeah
napomiacci's paid very quickly and he's
just played by the principles
he's just simply expanded on the right
side of the board open up even
open up lines just developed his pieces
i don't think he's put in too much
thought and calculation behind them
they're simply
practical and good enough and it is a
good a good approach basically
yep and uh it's the approach i try and
use as well for my chest when you play
moves that are just good enough
um and you can do that when there's no
immediate checks captures threats those
types of forcing moves where you have to
calculate a bit deeper
um okay meanwhile nakamura you we see
him shaking his head well we see the
side of his head but
we see it shaking and he's offered a
queen trade napoli actually
now he has the choice i mean a really
pleasant choice he can just trade the
queens if he wants to and be a pawn up
in a really promising end game
black has no compensation for that lost
pawn
um what would you do here ivanka just
take the queens and then start to
calculate after that
yeah i think i would probably take the
queens i mean
well i don't know but i mean i'm very
very tempted actually to keep the queens
on the board because i
you know as white i'm attacking actually
the king is unsafe
and also bearing in mind the clock
situation i think that the chances
of hikaru going wrong would be greater
in an
in a middle game true although napoli
actually he won't want to complicate
things too much for himself so maybe
taking the queens off
is the simple approach um that's not the
only one if we bring up the analysis
board there's two moves
um that i think stand out okay uh the
queens did come off the board janna
pogba if he was feeling greedy could
also have taken this pawn
with his queen but okay he took the
queens off and now i expect to see the
move
rook across attacking this pawn and once
that pawn drops black will be two pawns
down
not only okay he's played it uh not only
that but he was threatening to bring his
bishop up
check with a skewer that's why um
nakamura brought his rook across
trying to counter-attack against one of
white's pawns and there's a bit of a
trap actually because
can uh can napomnaty just simply capture
the pawn
and my idea is that after you play rook
takes pawn
then white could simply play rick takes
bishop
we like pins well maybe maybe not and
then and then
the bishop will pin it makes sense yeah
um pin and win here it's not completely
game over because black will just push a
pawn up and defend the rook but
it still looks pretty promising for
white simplifying down and
in this type of position white is still
a pawn up so decent winning chances
maybe there's something even better but
this is what jana pontiac
is thinking about right now in this
position will he take this pawn
will he just bring his rook across um
plenty of options you can even give a
check with your pawn
it's i mean i don't think there's a
right or wrong here napoli actually he
knows he's got several pleasant options
and
if he can maintain the tempo and keep
nakamura finding a siri i mean finding
forced moves just to survive then i
think eventually nakamura will crack
yeah all right looking difficult and
nakamura remembers well yesterday in his
two games with black against napoleoni
one of them he lost straight out of the
opening
the second one he was in a dead lost end
game after the opening so
nakamura clearly with the black pieces
is struggling right now
yeah definitely struggling and this is
really not the most
ideal start for hikaru you don't do not
want to begin
the match losing and this is such an
important match because of course the
winner of this match
will go straight on to the semi-finals
and that's just something that if you
want to stay in the competition you
can't allow
um but one thing bearing in mind you
know how napoli actually played
yesterday we did see
one error he rushed it yeah he got super
super impatient and then just
immediately took critical decisions
didn't use the time on his clock
and this is like a psychological factor
that you can
take advantage of and you can do this by
being smart with your moves okay so
napoli actually
he's learning from his mistakes and uh
sim took time out as now defending the
pawn with his rick
and again the ball is in hikaru's court
he needs to defend the pawn
what about just going mad and just
putting the rook all the way down
yep the rook is now attacking the bishop
and the pawn
and the drama is uh well it's happening
here
yep nakamura trying his best to continue
fighting
unfortunately though it's still not
looking good white's bishop is under
attack and maybe the best way
and the simplest way to defend it is to
use the rook at the top of the world
just drop down two squares capture a
pawn
and not only do you capture one of
black's pawns you also defend your
bishop
um the more i mean the more pawns come
off the board the more you'll suit
nakamura but unfortunately
i think white having this potential four
versus two advantage on that right side
of the board
that should end up being decisive um
yeah yeah he's he definitely has learned
from yesterday's mistake of rushing
he's spending a bit of time here and
he's right to do so
um the pognyacci still with a i mean
a vast choice here he can move his
bishop he can capture a pawn
okay he's about to make a move i think
again basically yeah he's taking the
pawn
and uh now is it worth a hikaru's while
just to kind of develop the bishop
to attack the rook before capturing the
pawn you know just to throw in some
pieces and throw you know just to
threaten the activity
yeah um black bishop attacking the white
rook would have made sense but
um okay um instead black if you didn't
see that
movie cory you were surprised by that
rock move by uh
yeah i mean i'm surprised that he's
surprised by it um because that's
white's most natural move
white was lining up the rook with the
black king yeah he looks in absolute
anguish there hikaru i mean this
actually brings up a very nice question
that we have from victoria
who asks us what do players have on
their screens during the game
just the board or also their opponent's
webcam because if i were napomniachi and
i were looking at hikaru
i would be rubbing my hands in glee
because chess is
not a not a polite sport
because you know it it does give you
some satisfaction to see
your opponent under some pressure and uh
especially if they're like doing this
like oh they haven't seen your move
you'll be like oh
no bonus bonus exactly so do you think
napomiacci is actually looking at
hikarus
i would i mean if i would play hikaru i
would just minimize that camera just not
look at it because he'll make faces
whether he's winning or losing
um okay we do see meanwhile napoli
actually push a pawn
hikara nakamura just brings this rook
across
again plenty of choice white rook at the
top of the board is perfectly placed we
call that the
seventh rank seventh heaven it is uh
that's where rooks want to be they've
got so many targets and
actually i think napoli actually his
winning plan is based upon that corner
pawn
on that right hand side he's he wants to
push it through and make a new queen he
will need the support of his bishop he
will need the support of his rook at the
bottom of the board but
um if he can combine his pieces somehow
now in the pontiac then
it's pretty much game over black is tied
down actually look at the top of the
board black's rook
black's bishop they're just defending
they're not doing anything and
as well as being upon down having
passive pieces
um that kind of compounds the misery
right now so is it that
h-bond harry porn yes that jana pognaty
hopes to make into a queen or
is will that be threatened by the black
king um i think he wants to make it into
a queen if we bring up the analysis
board while napoli actually thinks
um you've got the right idea kaya here
because the reason nakamura brought his
rook across
instead of getting greedy and taking
this pawn is because here white would
have had a winning move white could have
pushed the pawn forward
sacrificing it but clearing this line so
clearing the way for the pawn
for the rook sorry to support harry the
h-born this pawn is going to do the job
now this pawn cannot be captured by the
black king he's defended so the king
would have to go to
the corner and now also we've opened up
this diagonal
for the bishop and this would end up in
checkmate that is why nakamura he had to
step his rook across
to cover this square for the bishop but
sooner or later this idea will work it
doesn't work right now anymore
but um i think napoli actually he'll be
looking for the right time to push this
pawn forward
instead first he brings his rook across
he's aiming to
give a check or maybe even aim to bring
it the whole way to support
this pawn running through yeah he's
inviting all his pieces to the party and
that
is good good uh basically technique
and uh i really like that i mean they're
just mounting the pressure and
uh you know hikaru only has 42
seconds left and yeah
you can see hikaru is under pressure
definitely
tweet us and join in the conversation
using the hashtag chesschamps
and include pictures include absolutely
anything you want and
just make sure it's fun yeah
fun is always uh yes nice for us as well
here in the studio but okay meanwhile
nakamura he's not having fun you can
tell that on his face
he pushes a pawn forward he's just
trying to harass that white rogue trying
to stop white's rook coming across and
giving check
but as i highlighted i think napoli
actually he has bring his rook the whole
way across
support that pawn um okay he's got
plenty of squares
of anywhere that the white rook goes
where it cannot be captured i think it's
a good uh it's a good move right now
literally any square the main thing
though for napoli actually it's just not
to rush
he has to be calm cool collected aware
and if he does that no problems it's in
the bag yeah i mean this is instructive
for everyone at home as well if you
notice when the queens came off when the
pontiac
went into this winning end game with an
extra pawn
he had over 10 minutes and he spent half
that time just trying to work out the
details
trying to minimize the risk and that's
where to use your time when you you know
you've done the hard work you've won a
pawn
you've uh kind of killed the opponent's
counter play that's when to
kind of sit still just refocus and
yeah not take any chances okay meanwhile
nakamura trying to pick off that pawn
pick off harry
will harry survive here not completely
clear
it's not completely clear whether harris
survived but i mean at the very least
he can give himself away and just march
one step forward and
then then white will actually win two
pawns
yeah um so in this position if we bring
up the board we can see that
white's pawn white's actually white's
best pawn is under attack from the black
bishop
um personally i i'm quite protective of
harry i would just bring my rook over
and support this pawn and help it to
push forward later on but as ivanka
mentions the other option is to just
give it away sacrifice is pawn
temporarily king takes pawn and now
you've distracted the black king you can
capture this pawn when the king moves
again you can capture another pawn
and here white is two pawns ahead should
eventually win
um okay but he chooses to keep harry on
the board he brings his rook
across napoliacci nakamura takes this
pawn
and now i think this idea is coming the
one we highlighted a few moments ago
now this square is free for the bishop
maybe you can push your pawn forward
maybe you just push harry first
if you notice once the bishop gets to
this square the bishop will guard the
promotion square for harry so
that is the winning plan it's all to do
with this pawn right now
um okay there we go we saw this idea
earlier let's check out the players
faces as well
napoli actually he knows he's about to
win he's pushed that pawn forward
um okay nakamura he senses as well that
he's lost right now
um okay there we go bishop finds its
best diagonal
he's about to support the push of that
corner pawn harry is about to become a
lady
he's going to become a queen and um
okay well it's game over because
the bishop will be lost and that is it
hikaru has lost and the pomniacci has
won his first game
yeah i mean masterpiece mined upon me
actually looks so calm composed
in control throughout tough nakamura
fans he just never got in that game yeah
what a start for napogniachi after i
mean a disappointing ending to the day
yesterday not
finding that win in a winning position
striking back yeah totally and
the most impressive thing for me at
least was the fact that it was hikaru
the one who sprung the surprise who took
the game into
unchartered waters and look at
napomniachi
so calm and he just proved that he was
in excellent
excellent shape yeah this is a man that
is ready
this is do you think now david that it's
going to be
maybe not a smooth ride but he's uh do
you think now nepali will be able to
secure it
yeah i mean it's never smooth against
nakamura nakamura is a fighter
and he brings out his best in those kind
of brawling situations where he needs to
fight back but
um yeah napoli actually he put the
ghosts of yesterday to rest
he took his chances when they come when
they came and
um yeah napoleon actually looking really
good yeah and this
this game was really good so i would
love for you to take us
through the highlights here david yeah
and um i think
the key position came quite early on um
not just from a chess point of view but
also a psychological point of view
because here
uh white has just brought his knight to
the edge of the board attacking black's
knight
and nakamura spent 10 minutes on this
move
for black i think black only has one
move to stay in the game so nakamura at
this point
um i think this is where he just lost
the thread he lost
all chance of fighting back he ended up
taking white's knight
but a couple of moves later we saw in
this position
he went for the wrong plan simply he
pushed the pawn forward he panicked
giving naponnaichi an extra pawn here
white's rook
it might look like it's trapped but it's
perfectly supported by this bishop and
now
this is where the key move or the key
idea started white pushed his pawn
forward
this pawn continuing to rush rush up the
board and
later on after the queen trade we did
see
that in this position white has a
winning end game purely because of this
pawn he won the game
when this pawn was about to become a
queen later on uh yeah just a
classy display by janna pogiacci
in the next round we're going to follow
another very exciting one anish geary
versus maximum vagiela grab they tied
the first match so who's gonna win day
two or will it go to tie breaks
all right so these two are still playing
uh the first round game is going to
finish uh not too long obviously because
they don't have
uh that much time on the clock but
but that second gaming makeup between
these two it's going to be interesting
it's definitely going to be very
interesting isn't it you know absolutely
everything to play for
and this is this is the schedule for the
rest of the day so much fun
still to come we're going to get to know
the story of magnus becoming a
grandmaster very soon
it is all about the chess though with uh
four
games in the second quarter final match
and maybe maybe
after that we will have tie breaks
but we're also gonna have a lot of fun
we're gonna relax with
some fantastic chess we're also
challenging everyone at home
with our chess puzzles simon williams
he's made a lot of puzzles for you
and this is possible for uh day five
hello viewers of this brilliant chess
tour
ginger gm here with my puzzle of the day
today we're going to have a look at one
of rajaboff's
breakthrough games and breakthrough
tournaments
you're taking rajaboth with the black
pieces at the age of
15 or 16 16 i think in
the loners tournament in spain his one
of his first
tournaments at the elite level who's his
opponent
is it john smith from down the road no
it's
the fantastic gary kasparov
gary kasparov wasn't quite world
champion in this event losing it to
kramnik a couple of years before
but he was still incredibly strong and
losing to a 16 year old
is unheard of and that's precisely what
happened
here now black is a piece up but
converting this position
is a little bit tough what
is the best way to try and activate your
pieces as black here
or to simplify the position so make some
exchanges
what is the strongest move that black
can play here
think of your most passive pieces see
what you can do them
try to go forwards try to create some
frets
and try to use the bishop and king
on this file now have a good think about
that
as always uh if you want to cheat can go
over to chessboard look at the free
course over there
and see the answer otherwise i will
bring you the solution later on in the
day
live in the studio so i'll see you later
and enjoy the show
thank you simon looking forward to be
joined by simon later today after
game three so this is the puzzle of the
day you can find it
on champions chess or instagram twitter
account and facebook
but let's remind them david of what we
are looking for in the puzzle today
yeah so this is the puzzle position with
we're looking from the black side
we're looking from timor rajabov's side
he is playing against gary kasparov and
yeah simon is asking what is black's
best move
we're not looking for an immediate way
to checkmate in an immediate way to win
we're just looking to improve a piece
or simplify the path to victory
so yep like to play what's the best move
all right well
have fun working on this at home now
we're going to go get to know a little
bit better the grand master
magnus carlson now um when he was 12
magnus and his family left on a
year-long travel in europe
and he left as an international master
but he would return a year later as one
of the youngest
grandmasters in history so i have to
become a grandmaster this year
and is that realistic it's i think quite
realistic
he struggled a bit in the autumn trying
to take gm norms that turned out to be
difficult for some months
but then we had the month break after
he played a tournament in budapest
in november early december and during
that month
it seemed that everything he had learned
during the autumn
matured in a way
[Music]
he came back in january clearly with
grandmaster level strength and
created havoc in the sea group in
makansai basically
he took another gm norm in
moscow in february he didn't manage on
iceland in march
he had gotten his norms like
quite in the succession and then he
played i think the tournament in iceland
where he didn't get the
norm which he thought was really
disappointing and i mean
even though it was not a huge goal to
become like a grandmaster
at at a certain time point it's
uh you know it's cool to become a
grandmaster as early as possible because
that's something that stands there in
the history books for some time
i thought maybe he benefited a lot from
being young and underestimated
so that i more or less in every
tournament that spring
i expected that well maybe he stopped
winning maybe it's back to normal
now but uh at that point he had had
three or four very successful
tournaments and it went all so well in
dubai he had a lot of confidence
and with two rounds to go i think he
needed one point
to take care of gm norm before the last
game
that in that tournament in dubai he was
i think he was really excited and he had
done really great preparations
for that game i
still very much remember the the the
nervousness that i felt
um felt on the day and the game where i
finally got the title and my opponent i
think offered a draw
in in a somewhat worse position and
frankly i mean i couldn't have uh
couldn't have taken the draw any faster
because i just wanted
one of the titles we went to celebrate
at mcdonald's
which was like not like where we would
go to eat every day and
even got ice cream so proud dad
that's the international grand master
title
diploma that he received from fida so at
13 he became one of the
youngest ever
[Music]
it's funny to think of that it's almost
17
years ago i've been now a grandmaster
for much longer than i haven't
[Music]
17 years now magnus carlsen has been
a grand master becoming a grand master
at
13 how special is that david yeah it's
very rare
i mean a lot of the players in this
tournament they were prodigies i mean
you don't have to become a grandmaster
when you're young but it does help and
yeah he's been so experienced and his
progression i mean
it was slow and steady at first but once
he once he got that title it was
liftoff yeah and uh never looked back so
you were the same age as
as well right you're born same year as
magnus do you sort of remember this
when magnus became a grandmaster yeah i
remember and actually one of the
tournaments that uh his father henrik
was talking about in budapest i played
magnus and
at the time i think we were both
international masters and
he was a bit stronger but and i had a
winning position but he managed to kind
of
uh cause some tricks and it was a draw
in the end but i think just a couple of
months later he got that title
uh it took me two or three years longer
than uh longer than it did for magnus
but
um yeah i think it was very clear from a
young age he was always destined for the
top
yeah and uh i remember at the time it
was a big thing about who would be the
youngest in the world and
kariakin i think still holds the title
um sergey king who is in the prelims
of this tournament at 12 years old wow
um
yeah it's it's incredible some of these
players in their feats
so it is it isn't actually magnus
carlsen the world champion world number
one
with the highest rating of all time in
chess but he's not the youngest
grandmaster of all time even if he was
very young
no no certainly not as david mentioned
that pleasure goes to sergey karjakin
and it's it's quite funny actually
because they're very specific on how
many months as well because
i know everyone is desperately trying to
break that record
and uh no one has been successful yet
but they've come very very
close yeah which is very scary when you
think about it kaya
because it just means that they're like
13 years old yeah there's a
there's actually a group of young indian
players they all became a grandmaster at
12 but just a few months yeah
older than karjakin um yeah and i mean
if they continue the same trajectory as
carlson as karjakin then they in a few
years could be
um could be challenging for the world
title i think those indian grandmasters
they're all around 15 16 now
so a long way ahead for them yeah i
remember a few tournaments ago we talked
with an american
young guy i think he was nine years old
honey and he was aiming he said to be
the youngest grandmaster
um of all time but it's it's not easy
i guess it's not easy and you do
definitely need the right support
mechanism
uh behind you you do need an army of
trainers or maybe just
one very very good trainer and the right
support within you um
but yeah i mean okay i mean 12 years old
yeah
pretty i mean i don't think anyone
should be hung up on that achievement i
think it's enough to be a grand master
at 13
or 12 and a bit and uh just make sure
that the trajectory as uh david points
out goes up up
is there yeah so i was just going to say
it's never too late as well like i i
know plenty of grandmasters who became
well plenty of players who became
grandmasters in their 20s there was even
a case of a grandmaster
um at 60 i think when he won the world
senior championship he'd been playing
his whole life and he finally got that
title so
yeah it's never too late if you enjoy
the game and you keep making small
improvements here and there
not everyone's a prodigy do we know any
players from this tournament or any of
the top players who
who actually were late bloomers i think
david anton
was a relatively late uh bloomer i think
he didn't become a grand master until
much later i mean most of these guys
became grandmasters of 14 or whatever
but uh david and tom was slightly later
so what does it take david to become a
grandmaster just remind me of that
because it's kind of difficult some
something about some grandmaster norms
yeah it's a long long journey
um so there are a few titles before
grand master
um there's feed master which is uh when
you hit a rating of 2
300 you don't necessarily need any norms
or tournament performances you can just
apply for that but
once you aim for international master
which is the step below grandmaster
you need three tournament performances
where you beat another
you beat a certain number of title
players and you play a certain number of
nationalities
um and yeah once you have three of those
so three norms
then you become an international master
and it's the same for grand master as
well as having those three
strong tournament performances you need
to have the rating as well and that's
2500
for a grand master so magnus it was in
april
2004 then when he when he uh managed
this and became a grandmaster and his
sister told us here
they celebrated at mcdonald's do you
just miss those times when celebration
was that easy all i took was an ice
cream on mcdonald's
it still does no
pretentious thing for me here same for
you david
yeah i wish i could say mcdonald's
wasn't part of my weekly routine
i actually remember seeing magnus at the
tournament after he became a grandmaster
and i think they were still celebrating
so
rightly so rightly sir all right uh well
um
achievements uh not necessarily becoming
grandmaster but achievements that is the
theme
for the question of the day yeah exactly
as we as you said at kaya not everyone
can be an amazing chess player but
certainly they can be amazing and other
things in life and we are asking
what skills do you have or even aspire
to have
that are grand master level and
you can tweet your answers using the
hashtag chesschamps
send us your pictures the cooler the
funnier the better
and one lucky winner will win one of
these
beautiful little things uh air things
mini device
handy yes certainly all right
um so um
david if you were i mean do you have a
grandmaster level at
anything else anything else i don't have
too many other skills
um if i there's a there's a computer
game called football manager
and i think if they handed out titles
for that then i'd be a grandmaster for
manager but other than that
definitely not skiing definitely not ice
dipping
not too many other super skills
unfortunately how about yourself
well oh sudoku is that where you say in
english as well
yeah yeah i think i'm okay but i think
many other people are very good at that
as well and
i know where to get you for your next
birthday i love those big books
yeah and crossword puzzles as well i
love them but uh some of our audience
have got very special skills
i have to say can you imagine you're
looking forward to hearing them yes wow
we have a tweet from
tim fox who says he's 52 and just
started playing chess
and his grand master level skill is his
ability to blunder away
a game but keep coming back for more wow
i think we all sympathize with that one
tim
another one from mike d who says as a
father of two
little ones my gm skill is patience
so that's much
that's one of the most impressive skills
yes definitely
and then we have a very sweet one from
stephen wright who says i believe i have
achieved grandmaster status at
caring for my dog louis who is
terminally ill
i want to ensure his life's endgame is
as beautiful and peaceful as possible
and uh certainly that is such an animal
skill you know to be so caring and just
to look after
a pet your treasured friend yeah yeah
wonderful wonderful all right well keep
sending in them in those uh question of
the day
uh tweets we love hearing about your
skills i bet there are
many many nice guilds out there all
right let's head
back to the chest the quarter final
second matches
and uh let's take a look at the first
games of quarterfinals match two
the results and this is the first round
so look at that magnus carlsen winning
the first game against levon aronian he
now had
uh altogether three wins in that quarter
finals he's on fire the world champion
wesley so and ali reza russia they
played a draw
reservation needs to win today to take
it to thai breaks
we did see yana pomnyacci beating hikari
nakamura so he is looking good
in the second match they tied the first
one so did anish giri and maximum
vagielagram
and they also tied the first game
of today i actually looked a little bit
out there and looked like maxim
could be winning that but um yeah that
one it was a bit like yesterday's match
in total
uh in general fashion between bachelor
grav and geary it was a bit up and down
vashti de grav was doing well then giri
was doing well
and in the final position i think giri
was the only one who had chances to win
but
um yeah i mean plenty of exciting games
ahead yeah i mean magnus though he's put
to bed any
kind of lingering doubts about his
ability in the second day
of these matches he started with a bang
against aronian he's looking
back to his best for the world champion
i mean we do know that that levon hasn't
had the best tournament we
talked to him they switched the
federations over to the us so a lot on
his mind
no wonder he's sort of maybe not able to
focus
as much on the chest as he normally
would but not taking away anything from
magnus carlsen i guess he must be
playing his best chess so far in the
tour
yeah i mean i must say magnus's play
reminds me of a bit of a black hole he
just absorbs absolutely everything in
his way um
yeah he's been super impressive and uh
lavon ironian
back against the wall he really needs to
start fighting
unfortunately magnus is on form
and david actually kind of really looked
down on magnus's mindset he said
he's not interested in winning he's just
interesting in
playing good chess and just learning and
when you have this growth mindset
little things don't bother you you just
don't get stressed by the big picture
and that seems to be working that seems
to be working for magnus crossing so
does the
time zone he's sitting in let's head
into the place and we do know magnus
carlsen he's sitting
in his home in oslo norway it is uh
getting later i don't think that is uh
completely correct
yes it is i thought it was later no it
is six o'clock for
magnus crossing he seems to thrive in uh
this time zone at this time of the day
it is the same for niche geary
ali rasa brucia and maximum vaccine it's
getting quite late for jana pognachi and
live on ironian
but still very early in the day for the
americans
presley so and hikaru nakamura nakamura
a bad start to the day a loss against
jan
no pogniacci so he needs to find a win
in the next few games
to take that to thai breaks or else yana
pognashi will be the winner of that
quarter finals
it's getting close the second matches so
uh
we did say that we would follow
anishgiri and maximum vagiela grab but
we actually had to switch up
because magnus carlsen can actually
decide
the quarterfinal match against levon
ronian in this next one if he wins it
yeah i think magnus the way he's been
playing it wouldn't be a shock to anyone
if he does knock out irony in this next
game if you look at the head-to-head
scores now as well
four wins uh for magnus carson zero wins
for level neronian
this is just their score in the melt
water champions chess tour but
either way it's looking more and more
one-sided um yeah carlson full of
confidence right now and erroneous just
unable to get into the games
magnus carlsen he is eating again it's
not noodles this time it's a
salad right yeah like a healthy salad
for magnus today
this seems to be the time he's always
sort of uh
getting his energy up by eating after
the first game
heading into the second one
yep we are still waiting for a few
players to arrive but magnus crossland
and levon ironian
they are ready to fight it out in what
could be
could be their last game in the quarter
finals if magnus carlsen wins this one
then it will be over he will be the
winner
and head through to the semi-finals and
uh he does have the white pieces
so what should we expect yeah i think
magnus um
he will just try and be slow and steady
in this game he won't take too many
risks
remember magnus carson all he needs to
do actually today is get one point out
of these last
three games so especially with the white
pieces he won't want to
allow irony in a sudden kind of
miraculous fight back
um magnus as long as he draws or wins
this game he'll be very happy so
i expect a steady risk-free chess
from him irony and meanwhile it will be
interesting to see his approach does he
burn his bridges and throw everything at
this game
um and risk going kind of getting
eliminated early or does he
allow magnus to maybe force things
towards a draw
and gamble that he'll win the last two
games of today yeah this is
always the ultimate player dilemma do
you do what you say or do you just try
to be
as calm and rational and aware of every
possibility as possible i mean
it's not really lavon's style to kind of
just go
crazy he's kind of much more the kind of
astronaut type which is just simply
be calm and very collected
yeah usually aronian plays best when
he's ice cold and not
not kind of um kind of affected too much
by those emotions but
um yeah this is going to be a very
difficult moment because he knows that
the
his time is running out simply he needs
to fight back and i did love what i just
saw because uh levon aronian he just
took his webcam a little bit down and we
always see just the top of his head
because he
keeps sinking down in his chair so maybe
now we'll get the full level neronian
for this game
it has started it has started and we do
see a king's pawn opening
will magnus carson play spanish one of
his favorite openings will he play the
italian game
that we saw earlier in the clash between
the pogniacci and nakamura
magnus carlsen i mean maybe he doesn't
realize it's his move
um just pausing there and okay he plays
um
i mean this we call this the four nights
defense you can understand why
because all the four nights are out very
early in the game so
um four nights defense right now there
there are options
you can aim towards opening up the
center quickly which magnus carlsen does
um we yeah again we call this the scotch
four nights
because uh the scotch is when you open
up the center very very quickly it leads
to a lot of trades
and here we see a set of knights have
left the board
will we see both sides castle the king
magnus carson here
okay back to his food but he will most
likely castle his king
there's a second option if you want to
be a bit tricky if you want to play safe
if you want to um give a check with your
queen but magnus no he castles
and levon ironian does the same bit of
copycat there
um actually when i well in 2018 just
before
magnus carlsen played the world
championship match in london his final
warm-up event was the european club cup
and uh he was playing for volorenga a
norwegian team and i played alongside
him and i remember i had a chat with him
about this
opening wow so he's got ideas here i
wonder whether he'll use those that we
discussed
um but yeah either way this opening for
white it has a reputation
of being completely risk-free this is
the type of opening players choose when
they're happy with the draw
but they will try and apply a little bit
of pressure so um
it's not the most ambitious opening in
the world but it is pretty safe
so what what are we looking for here um
if he is going to follow
what you guys talked about um three
years ago
yeah i'm not sure i should reveal the
exact moves um that we discussed but
okay levon aronian he doesn't go for the
most popular move
for black so the conversation i had with
magnus about this opening
is not uh not overly relevant ah okay
well magnus he keeps on snacking on that
salad and i have to say it looks like
like a boxed salad that you would maybe
go out and buy on like a deli
not like something you would get take
out so you actually think that like in
these 15 minutes he has between games
he just ran out of his apartment to a
deli
bought his salad and went back in i
think more likely the fridge
yeah maybe he got it beforehand
maybe more likely yes um
yeah i mean it's i i find this quite an
interesting choice because
you know yes i can see that
white has really recently been playing
this particular opening for
a slight advantage but i remember as
when i
played this kind of particular position
with the black pieces i always
really liked it because i had pawns in
the center
and that's very easy to handle actually
and
you just simply keep making moves and
this is why i'm a little bit
suspicious of this particular approach
because you're you're
kind of playing into something that
lavonna ronin likes
yeah you're right lavon iranian does
like having extra central pawns if we
bring up the analysis board we see
this position is pretty balanced right
now the same material same pawns and
everything
but the key difference here is that
white has three connected pawns on the
left side of the board whereas blacks
are slightly broken black has an
isolated pawn here however he does have
a central pawn and this pawn especially
in the middle of the board
this one it could become a strength or
it could become a target
meanwhile i think the key priority for
black is to break this pin
you need to do something about the
tension here magnus right now is
thinking
i think what he's considering is
possibly to bring his queen out
to put even more pressure on this knight
and then levon ironian he will drop his
bishop back
just to kind of shore up the defense of
this piece
and then the plan will be to push the
rest of his central pawns forward
if he can push these guys in unison then
black has a great position
uh meanwhile magnus will just be
bringing his rooks across
not too many weaknesses in the white's
position that's why it's regarded as
pretty safe
and if magnus plays this move bring the
queen out if he um
other options would be to maybe reroute
the knight push a pawn up just to kind
of control some squares
lots of choice for magnus carson but
super solid
at the moment and he did i mean the
tournament i mentioned
in greece in 2018 he did play this
opening against ding lyren
in a key game and um he actually almost
lost that one
so although he said it was safety first
and in general it's played for
a small advantage for white there are
some risks as ivanka mentioned
if black's able to coordinate and start
pushing those central pawns then black
is doing okay
okay meanwhile magnus carson moves his
knight
i mentioned moving the night the other
way the knight goes well it just jumps
towards the left but
it's aiming back towards the center
later on and levon ironian reacts
instantly without even thinking he must
have done his homework here
levon um he must have been playing these
positions
for 20 odd years now love on ironian as
black and
he's pushing his pawns you like to see
it right ivanka of course
is that your style of chess exactly
there's no subtlety involved here no
maneuvering but
i have to say having sat next to you now
on uh on these shows i've now come round
to this idea of when you play the end
game
that you wait and you improve your
position as long as you can
and then you commit that little porn
move
and uh i've been uh i've been learning i
can't wait to try it out actually
i can't wait for the next time don't
blame me if it goes wrong
i don't think you can how can it if you
have a if you have a slight advantage
then you just keep making it does
require a lot of nerves though
a lot of patients you have to be careful
yes as that tweet said earlier you need
patience
in life not just in chess and uh
meanwhile magnus carson
i expect him um to maybe kick away that
black dark square bishop just push a
pawn on the left side of the board just
one square i'm not sure which pawn but
you can kick that bishop away kick it
backwards
slightly surprising white's last move
that night jump that knight looks
a bit offside now it doesn't look like
it has too many great squares to go to
uh maybe magnus carson just
underestimating black's reply
um yeah meanwhile okay he's still
tucking into his food
he won't be too worried this position is
still relatively uh
i mean not in that position but it's uh
you know it's actually we're still
in the depth of uh theory there's like
141 games in my database
that is a lot of games yeah i mean the
main move
is actually to chase away the black
bishop
you just have to just kick it play pick
up your pawn that's in front of the rook
place it one square and then just chase
that bishop away that's the main move
and then after that yeah we can show a
few lines
so uh yeah the main move would be to
kick away this bishop yeah but once the
bishop retreats
the whole idea is that once once you
said go where
once you kind of push that button you
have to continue and
uh that's why the porn move attacks
again
sorry advances again and uh no happens
if black gets greedy and takes this pawn
if blankets greedy then this is the kind
of the very crafty point behind it
you actually pick up your queen and you
slide it along that's it to the right
and then the whole point is that
actually the pawn cannot capture the
pawn because there is something that we
call the pin
in operation so if pawn takes pawn right
attacking white's queen
um this bishop is currently defended by
black's queen so you cannot capture it
but you try and deflect the black queen
i guess yeah you're gonna deflect it
first
yeah that's right and now black has to
ruin his own pawn structure
um it's really undesirable to do this
because if queen takes bishop then
white's queen jumps out and wins a piece
so
very sneaky stuff there i've never seen
that idea before i must confess
i've never seen it either actually so uh
you know we learn new things all the
time
yeah so clearly this i i mean this
concept is familiar
to magnus and he's just debating whether
to go into this um
let's check out the player's facial
expressions because um levon aronian
maybe has
just disturbed magnus with the speed of
his moves
this is probably what magnus was aiming
for that line that we just showed on the
board
and this is what magnus must have wanted
to play with that knight move
i mean there's no other point behind
that knight move simply but just
levon aronian replying instantly has
made magnus carlsen
second-guess himself and start um
considering whether he should actually
go for that type of idea
because there's actually nothing more
unpleasant in chess than
trying out an idea and realizing oh no
my opponent actually knows it better
they are better prepared than me um and
often in such
situations it's actually wiser to just
take just say okay
you've won the opening battle i'm going
to play something a bit different it's
not what i planned
but at least we'll both be on our own
and it becomes a battle of understanding
um instead of memory um so yeah magnus
carson if he senses aronian
will know what to do in that last line
that we showed then he might be looking
for something
a bit new a bit different well the bar
is definitely saying that this is
looking
um like a draw and magnus definitely one
who has spent the most time
in this game and on this move yeah we
we've said this in previous tournaments
uh
on the tour that magnus carson on the
second day he tends to get in time
trouble
he gets low on the clock very early on
and it's really rare to see him do that
um i mean in the prelims yesterday in
the first game today he was just playing
by instinct
playing quickly he was in a rhythm it
was working well there's a reason david
why he's uh
going down on the clock and that's uh
because he's
eating his salad and not playing
playing the board someone needs to have
a word with him now is not the time to
chill
you can eat after you've won this game
magnus
but yeah it's surprising to see him uh
spend so long on the clock
at this early stage he's only moved 12.
yeah and actually the first
what 10 11 moves i mean he's seen that
thousands of times before in his career
so
just on the last move or two he spent
about half his time
surprising stuff from the world champion
i must admit all right well let's see if
this is another moment where magnus
carlsen likey has done on so many of the
second days in the knockout stages
loses focus and starts sort of becoming
his own
worst enemy yeah not only is he
potentially losing focus but his
opponents they
surely gain confidence when they see him
not for not really concentrating
not really working out variations
hesitating in
rel in quite well known positions um
yeah i wonder what levon's thinking
right now well okay he's made his move
he has played
the most common response and now levon
just has to step the bishop back okay
and now it comes
the pawn steps forward and we're going
to see that line actually
where if levon does capture the pawn
then the queen will just slide itself
crafty to the right
and that's an idea i've actually never
seen before and i know you said that you
also
hadn't seen it and all the times that
we've actually met this opening
yeah i've i've played this opening with
white and black since i was what five
years old and i've never seen this exact
idea
um before and i mean there's so many
nuances so many options for both sides
um so okay maybe
levon aronian is familiar with it maybe
not maybe he's a bit like us and hasn't
seen it but
either way magnus plays the most common
idea it's just surprising to see it take
him
seven and a half minutes to do that um
it feels like this idea especially that
queen move that we showed on the board a
moment ago
shifting that queen across one square
it's the type of move that no human
would
it wouldn't just not be on your radar
simply um so it's the type of move you
either know it or you don't
so that's why it surprises me that
magnus has already lost seven and a half
minutes
um probably he knew it and he just
wasn't ready to make it yeah
okay so levon has chosen the actually
actually the most popular response
which is to treat the bishop and again
we are still very much in the realms
of everything haven't been played and
seen before
so we did see a trade of horns magnus
quickly pushing upon there
um so with magnus carson's last move
he's just trying to stop the advance of
black central pawn
maybe he's trying to take control of
some squares for himself
this position very balanced um still the
same
assortment of pieces both sides have
reason to be happy here i think
the only issue for levon aronian is okay
despite the fact he has a big time
is how do you create some play how do
you disturb white's coordination how do
you
get active yourself before magnus is
able to kind of
hoover off all the pieces for example um
it definitely feels like magnus isn't
necessarily playing for the win in this
game
it feels like magnus would be happy with
the draw on this one but for levon
that's
not good enough he needs to yeah he
needs to do something do you think
magnus is sort of
relying a little bit on that because we
do know if you push too hard
then you can create chances for your
opponent so magnus knowing that lavon
has to find
two wins in one of the three in two of
the three
last games do you think he's just
waiting for lavon to
to be too brave yeah i mean that must be
the strategy right
he's hoping that uh levon will maybe
start overthinking things
uh start to feel the pressure of the
situation and
um yeah that could backfire on level but
then again if magnus
plays too passively plays too much for
the draw um i've learned this from my
own experience but
i i mean every top player that i know
would say the same
if you play for a draw it will backfire
um it will come back to haunt you
the best way to play for a draw is
actually just to play for a win and
often
later on you'll get chances to repeat
the position or you'll get chances to
simplify
if you go too passive if you just kind
of curl up into a ball
often it's not good enough your opponent
will find something
later on to destabilize you and
now this is actually a very very rare uh
line that
magnus has chosen i mean the last time
it was played was in 2018
and before that 2016 the highest highest
level that's been faced with alex alex
shiroff
alexis shiroff sorry he was having the
black pieces in 2016.
but before that we're looking at 2006
and then before that we're looking at
1998 and uh it's super super rare and
well levon seems to know what he's doing
all the moves are intuitive
so he's attacked the bishop and magnus
has retreated the bishop
keeping his eyes on that pin
yeah so this position it tends to arise
once every ten years or
thereabouts um yeah very rare stuff
um like a meteor or something from space
shooting stuff
yeah but sometimes that's the kind of
way to do your opening preparation i
know
bobby fisher he was famous for picking
up the old books and kind of scouring
them for old ideas
and i do know i remember having this
conversation with simon williams
where this was in 2008 when we were
playing in the european
um individual championships and he was
saying that
he had done some preparation in a line
that had last been seen in 1898.
should have said to simon you know it's
probably not been seen since
for a reason well no one said that and
we
the brits don't say that the brits go
well done simon
good going yeah and um
okay meanwhile magnus carlsen has
centralized his knight
um he's been preparing this outpost um
which black cannot challenge with pawns
uh magnus has been preparing that square
with his last four or five moves
um so a very sensible idea by magnus
carson that
knight is traded but at the cost of
black's bishop and this shows that levon
aronian
um okay he just wants to simplify things
his winning chances are dwindling though
the pawn structure
is almost symmetrical black's actually
created a weakness of his own in front
of the
black king this has actually come back
to uh
bite aronian in the past we've seen him
push a pawn in front of his king and get
punished by wesley so by magnus
by several others but in this position
it just looks too
simplified black's knight is getting
ready to capture a bishop
um if that knight trades itself off for
one of the two bishops
then the position is just completely
balanced um
yeah i think this uh this position is
fizzling
towards what uh opening theory
theorists call equality where chances
are completely balanced
not too much so hope for for either side
i would still slightly prefer to be
white to be honest because white's king
is safer
but that's not such an issue because
black's king although it's a bit exposed
there's just no white pieces to attack
it right now
um yeah magnus he's just
maybe he's just having that kind of uh
philosophy philosophical chat with
himself just thinking
okay do i risk it do i go in the attack
do i just allow this uh
this draw to happen and um kind of ask
liv on whether he can win the final two
games on demand
it must be a little bit of a nice
feeling for levon as well i mean
you just have nothing to lose yeah
yeah many people thrive on it but then
again i mean he's still in the
tournament
so that's something to lose yeah well
please just get eliminated
um but yeah i mean it's now or never
essentially for him
yeah i was slightly surprised by levon
aronian's opening choice i mean it's
principled it's what he normally does
but
um it's really kind of last chance
saloon
so um yeah i mean maybe he'll just be
aiming to draw this game
if he can win with white which i mean
levon aroni is so strong with the white
pieces if you can win with white in the
next game
then in the final game with black that's
where levon ronia will take some crazy
risks
that's when he'll be thinking about kind
of nothing to lose yeah um
type of mentality but okay that's uh
at the moment he just needs to stay in
this game
magnus carlsen bring the queen out
white's queen eyeing up a pawn
um along the same line black's only
unprotected piece right now is that pawn
so
magnus playing a very logical move yeah
and do you have a question actually from
michael denucci who asks us will these
gm
struggle to adjust back to
over-the-board chess
after getting so comfortable playing at
home online
that's an interesting question yeah
really interesting
and actually we saw it in the tata steel
masters in january
right where the winner of the tournament
was actually jordan van ferest
and i mean some of the superstars like
magnus carlsen like fabiano caruana
he i mean actually fabiano was very
impressive but magnus just wasn't at his
best somehow
yeah maybe he'd been playing uh maybe he
just struggled to get back in that
mindset and get back in that room
nbl as well struggled didn't he and they
all struggled big time oh yeah
yeah totally i mean but interestingly
enough uh fabiano has actually
declined to play i mean he publicly
announced in tata steel
he was not going to play these online
events he was simply going to focus on
over the board
so i mean he's kind of made that
conscious decision in preparation for
the candidates
but uh it does mean he's not playing
that much though doesn't it
yeah he's gonna lose that edge that
competitive edge because you can see
these guys i mean you can even see anish
and nisha said this is like perfect
training
for his candidates tournament because
you got to get that competitive edge
that
killer instinct going and uh
this is a fantastic training ground
let's face it yeah
yeah i mean uh fabiano carowanna maybe
he'll rethink his stance if the
candidate doesn't go so well maybe he'll
kind of get restless get achieved and
want to play in these online tournaments
but
um for yeah for players like anish giri
i mean he's been playing in all these
tour tournaments and then
tata steel masters he almost won it um
and he
played a phenomenal chess so it
definitely didn't hurt him
i think it just takes some people longer
than others to get back in the shape and
get back in that
uh get back in the mood yeah for over
the board classical chess
it's not just being at the board it's
also the time control tata steel masters
each game would be like
uh it'll be a seven hour time limit for
one game
um and yeah it's takes stamina it takes
endurance yeah and i have to say the
magnus has been eating a salad he's been
playing very slowly
these first moves but he seems on his
camera to be a little bit restless now
it almost feels like
uh something is coming oh look at that
jana pomnyachi has won also the second
game
against hikaru nakamura that means he's
only going to need a draw in the next
game to be the winner of that quarter
finals wow
yeah incredible i mean nakamura has just
lost that game with white in 28 moves
you nearly never see nakamura lose with
white
let alone so quickly and the
we saw it in the last game we said it
he's looking good he's uh
it feels like something's clicked for
him um also note giri is winning his
game
and nepali actually those two they're
preparing for the candidates they're in
training mode
and it's really helping their chess yeah
look at that
a dramatic round and we do know the
reason we're following this is because
this
could be over after this game if magnus
wins it
wow let's take okay yeah magnus just two
moves ago he brought his queen out
from its start square to the left side
of the board now
two moves later he's brought it back to
where it came from
ivanka i'm struggling to explain that
logic
help me out here because that move it's
just blown my mind
why bring your queen out if you're just
going to retreat her two weeks later
it does that doesn't quite make sense i
mean i totally agree with you there
david
no logic at all behind the move
i mean all i can think of is that the
queen perhaps wants to
go over onto the right side or perhaps
he's kind of realized
i made a mistake the queen doesn't
belong there she belongs
in the middle of the board flexible and
then he's going to try to swap off rooks
but i'm also slightly baffled because
i really would have thought that he
would have locked down the position a
little bit because
all he needs is a draw and i was
expecting him to perhaps instead of
coming going out with a queen
perhaps to kind of challenge the black
rook using his
own rooks because this is something that
magnus himself likes to do he loves to
play with all his pieces and he's not
doing that right now
and i'm also concerned about the clock
time because
uh magnus is just under four minutes
whilst
levon aronian has just under 11. that's
a
significant time of divine yeah i mean
we saw him just a few moments ago as
well magnus shaking his head
um quite vigorously he he is not happy
with how developments have been going
in this game he still got things under
control but he essentially did lose two
moves there with his queen
those moves could have been used more
productively to get those white rooks
into the game
um meanwhile okay black's rook under
attack
imagine how much he'll be kicking
himself if he's somehow kind of
makes a mistake under time pressure and
allows levon back into this match i
think
yeah magnus maybe magnus may be relaxing
just a bit too soon with the food and
just losing losing his rhythm yeah i
mean he's totally lost the original i
mean
just look at it i mean lavon has been
allowed to
double his rocks on an open line and
magnus again has no clear plan
but they know the unfortunate beauty of
chess is that sometimes you can make a
mistake and that's it
game over and other times you can make a
series of inaccurate moves and
actually the position is still level yep
and i and i have a suspicion that it's
probably the second case which is
absolutely
apparent here because yes he's messed
around with his queen
but ultimately a few correct defensive
moves and
magnus is okay yeah the good thing for
magnus is although he
he hasn't played in the most ambitious
way he's still got passive pieces
um he lost those two moves earlier with
that queen maneuver
despite all of that he still has no real
weaknesses for white and
pieces are disappearing we just saw the
final set of minor pieces the final set
of bishops disappear and
um the more pieces leave the board the
closer we get to a draw so
yeah he's taken real liberties in this
game he's he's uh
done many things that i wouldn't advise
to those starting out interests
you don't want to bring a piece out and
retreat at the next move all of that
stuff
but magnus is magnus and he's still got
things under control
um note that the white king is safe and
as long as that hap as long as that
remains the case
with the major pieces the queens and
rooks on the board then
white should be should be okay yeah
yeah protect the king and everything
will follow
that's uh that's a nice line that i
learned today yeah
yeah i mean one thing as well that i've
learned is um in the queen of rook
games it's just all about king safety
sometimes it doesn't matter if you're
pawn down or two pawns down sometimes
even three pawns down
if you have the safer king um then you
always have a chance and
yeah magnus with his last move bring the
rook up the board attacking the black
queen
and attacking that black pawn in the
center
i am slightly surprised already and
traded those bishops i must admit but
but okay um aronia now can offer to
trade queens he can step his queen back
a few few options for lavon
who would you prefer here if you had to
choose i know it's roughly balanced
you've anchor but
who would i choose i probably would
choose um
whites yeah i would probably choose
choose white just just because of the
unsafe king
and i have to say i do really like that
tweet from jafar87
which is all about uh having studied
how after studying his games lavon
aronian comes up with a sound offense to
magnus carlsen
the peanut counter gambit
yeah it's just in response to the noodle
the noodle opening
the cold salad opening today
so what's your favorite salad type david
caesar salad that's my favorite salad
with some crisps on top
i actually had that okay so i hope my
mom is not watching but
i traveled to england when i was kid
with my best friend her mom is from
wales
so actually i was in wales yeah oh are
you
yeah that was the worst name ah i love
it there but yeah yeah they served
they served me like a sandwich with just
chips on it
and i loved it we make
unhealthy foods it's crispy chips
chips like french fries yeah well not
french fries but
you know you have a bag of chips uh okay
we say crisps oh crazy okay so that's
chris
yes yes yes so in us they will say chips
right right okay crisp
so yes a sandwich with crisps is what i
had when i went to wales
my flatmate at university for three
years he all he ate was a sandwich with
christmas
that's so unhealthy
yeah i mean that's that's unhealthy but
at the moment both of these players
their positions are
pretty healthy um they both look fine
and good trying to turn things in
but um yeah levon aronian the reason
he's thinking here with black is he's
just looking for ways to imbalance
things
to maybe set a trap for magnus um just
to force magnus to be accurate before
the game
does head towards the draw but okay
levon iranian i don't think he found
a direct path to to create any threats
and now the queens have disappeared
white is temporarily a pawn up but if
you look at white's rook in the corner
it's very passive
so in rook end games just having more
active pieces
should compensate for the lack of a pawn
um
levon aronian yeah i think he should
draw this game despite the fact he's
born down but
that won't be that's not gonna be
sufficient i mean
absolutely not then that means that
magnus will be half a point away
from winning the match and going into
the semi-finals
um certainly not ideal and actually the
way it's looking
right now i know we don't have the games
on the bottom here but maybe we can get
them up so
ayano pognacci now has won two games so
if he only gets a draw in the next one
that will be over he will be in the
semi-finals
wesley so it's looking like he's winning
against daly rest of russia yeah we see
it there
and if he does um i guess he only needs
a draw
also in the next round to be through to
semi-finals it does look like
a niche geary is uh looking good against
maximum vagina
and i guess with that win and a draw in
the next
no he'll need another witness okay so
not 100 sure that we will be
done after three rounds yeah but i mean
i think the biggest shock would be if
there
aren't tie breaks yes um i mean these
players they're also good they're also
um so close but um okay meanwhile there
have been some developments in this game
so a set of pawns have been traded so
remember
white is still a pawn up white has one
extra pawn on that left side of the
board
but the problem is white's rook next to
the white king it is just so passive
black's rooks are perfectly placed this
is where you want your rooks in
rook and pawn end games you want them on
the seventh rank you want them behind
your opponent's past pawns and
sooner or later white's extra pawn will
drop um
okay magnus just waiting with his last
move bringing the rook back
that doesn't really improve his position
but sooner or later levon okay there you
go
there he goes he's he's heading for that
extra pawn
that white pawn is going to drop off
it's just going to be three pawns
against rook and three pawns
no chance to break through not enough
material left and the game will be a
draw
look at this it's completely balanced
right now and the players they'll find a
way to make a draw
um here we go i think we're going to see
it the pawns are going to get exchanged
and
yeah this is just completely drawn
nothing
to see here actually just the players
would just be moving around their rook
and that's it there's just no way to
make progress yeah
and the thing with rook and games is
there's no way to actually force a trade
of rooks for either side
and if you avoid a trade of rooks as
without past pawns on the board which
will just run down to make a queen
without those there's just no way to win
so two pawns against two pawns on the
same side is a very simple draw and
there we go uh draw has been agreed
and manchester shaking his head for the
first time not too
happy um about his game and this got
final yeah he was
quite unconvincing in that game to be
honest but he is a step closer to the
semis
so in the grand scheme of things he will
be relieved but look at
the vulneronian just making a plan now
for what he's going to
unleash against magnus in that next game
it needs to be
something winning yeah he has to win i
mean that's it there is nothing
else that can actually suffice and uh
yeah well what's he got he's got the
white pieces
that's in his favor and he will simply
have to take his opportunities when they
present himself
this is the time now he's burnt the
bridge
he needs to go all in for the attack and
uh the only way to do that we've seen
dubois get the upper hand of magnus
and he has to play in an uncompromising
way
and play to his strengths just do not
take magnus into an end game that's my
big big advice yeah because that
that has been magnus's trouble in these
uh days
two's uh david a little bit of unfocus
yeah and then it's downhill yeah it's as
if he senses that the finishing line is
just there and then
the closer he gets the more he just
stumbles uh sometimes magnus carson
at least in the past so far he's looked
pretty good that last game though it
wasn't a great sign for the world
champion
um yeah levon aronian he'll take
confidence from the fact he was never in
trouble
in that last game and now he is
really in that nothing to lose situation
levon ironian will be throwing
everything
forward towards magnus's king and maybe
we can take a look at this game i mean
it wasn't all that spectacular yeah but
it was a little bit exciting in the
opening here and and
you did have some excitement some
excitement in the opening and actually
um for me the most interesting moment
was actually this point
um when magnus uh decided to bring his
queen out
magnus's queen jumped out to this square
eyeing up one of black's pawns this pawn
not currently protected
but after knight takes bishop trade here
black's rook dropped down
attacking white's bishop and this is
where magnus carlsen
already quite low on the clock made a
bizarre decision
he decided okay rather than move this
bishop rather than protect it with a
rook
which is probably what i would have done
he dropped his queen back
the queen only coming from the square
two moves ago so magnus
just giving up those two moves for free
and
he did look in a small bit of trouble
after black's queen jumped forward
later on potentially eyeing up this
vulnerable pawn however magnus he stayed
calm
and after some trades later on
especially when the bishops came off
especially when the queens came off as
well
he guided this one safely towards a draw
magnus not at his best but it's been
good enough
all right
we will be looking at the third game
with levonorone and then magnus crossing
because we know we live on a ronin
there's no other result for him than a
win
a draw or a win for minus means the
quarterfinal is over magnus will be
in the semi-finals
all right well uh it's a short round
round two on day two quarter finals all
games
finished before they were played for 35
minutes so that means we have a little
bit of a break
and what i'd love to do in these breaks
is to learn a little bit more chess from
david howell we have made the howl's
how-to videos and this next one is very
excited
it's got a weird name it's called the
smothered mate
in order to improve at chess it's
essential to study
checkmating patterns often the same
patterns come up all the time
the patterns won't always be the same so
you have to recognize them instantly
and once you start to learn these
patterns your game will improve
an enormous amount one of the most
popular patterns the most famous
patterns that will crop up i guarantee
in your games is called smothered mate
this happens when a knight actually
checkmates on its own
this is going to be one example of
smothered mate smothered mate
tends to happen when a knight
checkmate's on its own
we call it smothered mate because
actually the black king here
smothers itself it suffocates itself it
has nowhere to run
blocked in by its own pieces and pawns
this is why it's smothered mate the
knight jumps in giving check
and the black king simply has nowhere to
run this
usually happens in the corner of the
board when the black king
is completely trapped and here the white
knight delivers checkmate
this is what you're aiming for at the
end this is smothered mate
but the patterns building up to this
tend to be
familiar they tend to be similar a lot
of the time so we will see
what you should aim for in order to get
this smothered mate
so in order to build up to smothered
mate this is one
possible starting pattern it normally
begins
with a queen checking the opponent's
king
here the black king is very vulnerable
along this diagonal it has only two
squares to run to
it doesn't help bringing the black rook
forward because this black rook will
simply get captured with the same
check therefore black should choose from
two
possible king moves the problem is if he
runs away
towards the center then often there's a
very simple checkmate
the queen simply attacks the black king
supported by this knight
the black king is trapped and mated
therefore instead
the black king usually tries to hide in
the corner
and this is the build up this is the
start
of the smothered mate white gives a
check the black king again
only has one square to run to the black
king has to step across and now
the key build up the key preparation
for the smothered mate you have to give
a double check with your knight
and your queen with double check the
only thing the opponent can do is move
the king he doesn't have time to take
one of the checking pieces
because the other piece attacks the king
once again if the king steps to the side
this is checkmate therefore the king
should try and hide in the corner
and the final step to secure the
smothered mate is to actually sacrifice
the queen
to force the black pieces to suffocate
to smother its own king
white sacrifices the queen on this empty
square and when black
captures this queen we see this pattern
again
knight steps in checkmate the black king
is trapped by its own pieces and pawns
so here is another example of smothered
mate with an
added element usually the smothered mate
does begin with the queen and
knight the queen will be the piece that
sacrifices itself
but often you do need a bit of finesse
so
as usual we check the black king along
this diagonal the black king has to step
to the corner
now we see the same idea white steps
forward with a knight
delivering check and this time there's a
difference black can actually capture
this knight
but now we see the added element white
can actually deliver a different
checkmate
backrank checkmate the black king is
also trapped
in this scenario and after the rook
steps back this
is checkmate this is why in
the previous position black has to step
away with the king
or else walk into that background
checkmate the king steps to the side
and now once again the smothered made
pattern begins
double check the queen attacking the
king and the knight attacking the king
the king has to hide in the corner and
this
key sacrifice which you all have to
remember white sacrifices the queen
luring the rook to a bad square boxing
in its own king
and now the smothered mate the knight
delivers checkmate on its own
this is another example of a smothered
mate from a real game
but this time the smothered mate is in a
slightly different form
in this position you can't actually
start checking with your knight
because the white knight here is pinned
the black rook
would attack the king if this knight
moved
therefore we have to find a different
idea and this time
we start with the queen sacrifice
bringing the queen
to this square it cannot be captured by
the king because the queen's actually
defended long range by this bishop
therefore the black rook has to capture
this queen
now the pin is broken and therefore we
can deliver the killing blow
with our knight the knight is always the
piece that delivers the smothered mate
in the end
all right i'm just sitting here with my
cup of coffee trying to learn and this
looked beautiful i have to say this is
this basically the aim
you have in any chess game to just you
want to end up with this
yeah it's one of the coolest most
satisfying mates to deliver and
uh especially when you're coming through
the ranks when i was young for example i
got these
all the time and just recognizing that
pattern having the queen of knight combo
it will save and win you many games but
yeah towards the top level they tend to
see it coming that's the only problem oh
yeah so we haven't seen it in this
tournament
no no unfortunately not i know it's my
favorite checkmate actually
i mean i really do like sacrificing my
queen
and just using my knight to deliver
check mates
and the beautiful thing about it is that
the king is completely jammed in
by its own pieces and it just can't get
out and i can't tell you enough
how satisfying that is
i mean it's like the height of evilness
fantastic well
uh we're so happy right now to be joined
by international master
lawrence trent from berlin actually are
you in germany lawrence
i i am in germany yeah i uh i they they
won't let me back in
so i have to stay out here no i've been
here for a while now and
uh hopefully that lets me stay in the
country
with brexit going on and everything else
who knows who knows
so laurence what's your relationship to
the smothered mate
my relationship to the smothered me it's
a metaphor for my life
that's my relationship uh
no the smothered mate is uh it's a beaut
as
ivanka and david say you know you when
you played
chess for for a very long time you have
lots of chances to get in this mate
especially when you're younger it's
it is one of the most satisfying uh
checkmates it's it's
aesthetically beautiful and after all
should we play chess because we're com
competitors we like winning but there's
an artistic element to chess
that if you spoke to all of these
players they would agree
you know that the aesthetic element how
how positions look
is is a big part of the pleasure we
derive
from from the game so uh looking forward
to the next one
okay i want to ask all of you a question
and this might be a super stupid
question by a non-chess player but
is it sometimes hard to make a move
because it just
ruins the symmetry in like a beautiful
position that you will have
i i would say yes actually i mean
sometimes
you everything's so picture perfect you
don't want to touch it
unfortunately we can't just like put up
a beautiful position and say look how
beautiful it is
i win the game we actually have to make
a move and
it pains you to make that move but it
that's absolutely true that sometimes
you have to put
a piece on an ugly square an awkward
looking square so
there's certainly an element to that i
would say do you guys have that as well
yeah completely um sometimes you just
want to sit there and admire things and
in order to win the game you actually
have to
give up your worst uh your best piece
and um yeah we've all been there yeah
usually i
i find the kind of situation you know i
have a beautiful position
it's all perfect but there's no way
through and so i have to make something
and so i pick up and i'm like i have to
oh it pains me to make that ugly move
but uh okay
we do it yeah well um lawrence we
we were joined by you in the last
tournament in the opera euro rapid and
we were talking about
your sort of goal of becoming a grand
master you're an international master
we've seen the story today about magnus
carlsen becoming a grandmaster at
uh 13. so i just want to check in how's
it going i mean there's no over the
board tournament so
it must be hard yeah i mean it's it's a
bit unfortunate at the moment because
obviously
um the corona situation is
well it's actually getting worse over
here in europe we heard some news that i
think
france has put in some new lockdown
measures
germany's cases are going up daily
uh quite seriously they're well over the
mark where they're thinking
you know if they're going to reduce the
lockdown so
uh that's going to be the most one of
the most difficult parts of this entire
journey is actually
being able to play so at the moment i'm
i haven't planned any tournaments or
anything like that uh i'm going to uh
start a full regime
uh very very soon uh when things have
really
started to look like they're going to
get back to normal-ish
obviously probably uh when i've got the
vaccine as well
i'll i'll feel a lot better but yeah
it's just very unfortunate the situation
at the moment it's just i can't see
there being many tournaments happening
in europe
for you know if the situation gets worse
i mean today was terrible
uh who knows and i'm gonna need to play
a lot of tournaments in order to get it
so
that's going to be a big obstacle yeah
you said that you were doing
um the you're going to start training
very very soon but what are you doing
now what kind of foundation
are you laying well i'm doing what
everybody else should be doing which is
watching your broadcast
everybody out there hope you're learning
um so uh one big part of what i'm i'm
actually doing which might surprise a
lot of people is uh fitness
work so um getting getting back fit is
actually quite a big thing
suffered quite a lot during lockdown i'm
getting back to boxing which is good
i've got my trainer
wow doing yeah uh so i'm i'm back uh
back training with him um
i i run i've actually just got delivered
today some new running gear
so getting physically fit is i feel like
the first thing i want to do now uh
before i really get
stuck into the chest stuff um and yeah
the chest stuff is a
is is of course the main part but that
comes
that comes in lots of different sections
and
but for the moment i just feel like i
want to get fit again and i'm quite
pleased with my progress
so that's the first stage there's always
chest boxing lawrence if the
chess itself with the grand master title
is elusive well it's funny you say that
but i am actually a member of the gym
here in berlin
uh where it all began actually uh
there's a there's a london division but
here in berlin the chess boxing gym
and the chess boxing community is is uh
it's a really nice small community and
unfortunately the gym is still closed uh
but when it opens again i'll be going
back
and uh uh yeah it's a great spectacle
actually i think that's a conversation
for another day but chess boxing really
is a fantastic concept
i want to watch that more yeah well
don't worry why watch it i kya
you know you're fit i've you know i've
i've seen you you
know i can see you in the ring maybe
that would be my sport
yeah well the thing is what they're not
telling you actually
is that chess boxing is mainly boxers
who have retired from the game and have
uh picked up chess
so it's very rare that it's actually a
chess player that that decides hey
i don't know maybe i would be more a
boxer than a chess player i'm not quite
bored i'm not quite sure what category
i'm most
how's your left how's your left hook
kaia can you give us your left
yeah that's a that's a decent straight
left yeah i like that you're covering
the face
yeah yeah that's pretty good yeah all
right
that's what you should do to these guys
after the tournament to motivate them
yeah
i don't know if you've seen lawrence say
uh the girls here they've been bullying
me into doing all these challenges maybe
the next challenge should be kaya no no
no no no no no
well actually i want to try that that
sounds like a lot of firewall
i want to say congratulations i did
enjoy seeing you
half naked david also then ivanka even
and uh but i do want to see kaya get
involved
you know i think she's got it she said
she's got it good there sitting in a
nice chair
you know getting a coffee just bossing
around these two
yeah bossing them around i think it's
time to put kaya
to the test so well all the producers
out there listening
let let's make it happen we're open to
ideas
well okay i'm i'm switching the subjects
i don't want any challenges and
well getting fish and all that lords
isn't inspired by magnus carlsen
basically has he sort of
made that a big thing in the chess world
like you know of course your chest braid
needs to work but you also need to be
fit
well magnus certainly has in recent
times bobby fischer was really the first
guy who put it on the map if you watch
any
documentaries about bobby fischer i mean
uh
he looked more like a swimmer than he
did a chess player
he was uh in extremely good shape gary
kasparov as well
if you watch some old school clips of
gary you'll see him working out at his
random resorts with his uh soviet
trainers
and obviously then magnus nowadays has
been uh
really the guy who has shown just how
not just important is but essential
is the word uh i'm looking for you you
cannot be
uh the top of the top in the world now
without
having a high level of physical fitness
so himself
of course and then i think of fabiano
caruana fabi who i work with as you know
for many years um the physical part of
the regime was
an extremely important part and people
might ask well why do you need to be fit
to play chess and the simple answer is
if you're going to sit there for six
hours eight hours at a time
and try and maintain a high level of
concentration
you need to be fit if you're not fit
you're just not going to be able to
maintain that intensity
so that is a big part and uh
you know long gone are the days where
you're going to see
kai you might not have even known this
but they used to smoke at the board
cocktail glasses yeah they used to smoke
at the board drink
you know one [ __ ] in one hand drinking i
mean it was absolutely incredible
nowadays
you've really got to just have um an
athlete's body if you're going to
compete and there's just no other way
we were born in the wrong era lawrence
you could talk i mean so we've got eight
uh very athletic very physically fit uh
chess players in the quarter final who's
impressed you the most so far um i have
to say i'm gonna go to the champ
actually the champ
is is back he had a very underwhelming
tournament last time around didn't he
um and he's back with the bang he's
absolutely crucifying levon with black
with white
levons just uh on the ropes magnus
looked good in the
preliminary stage as well and i think he
wants to make a statement now magnus is
uh he doesn't like to lose and um
it's not that he just doesn't like to
lose he doesn't like to underperform
that's his big thing i think he he he
hates underperforming more than losing
if he loses to her brilliancy he'll just
put his hands up and say you know the
guy played brilliant
but to play under his level is something
that really annoys him
and this tournament we've seen him just
slowly get back to that level that we're
very used to seeing him at and he's
impressed me i want to say also that
uh well i think wesley has been very
good and uh yeah the punishing
you know jan uh he uh he's had a few
moments where you know he should have
won this game or he's kind of uh been
under pressure and
but he's managed to somehow turn things
around at the right moment so jan as
well
has impressed me magnus um
ali reza's not really sean at all in
this uh
yet so he's got a lot of a lot of
maturing still to do
and the anish against maxine match has
obviously been very very tight
uh but really magnus is is the standout
and
if he if he continues like this he's
just going to win the tournament
in my opinion well laurence i actually
want to ask you because being the magnus
carlson invitational we are focusing a
lot on magnus and
making the videos to sort of tell the
story of magnus carlsen
and i keep seeing you in there when we
keep talking about
the 2013 world championship match
commentating there your pitcher is
always
uh up there and magnus is uh keeps
saying that sort of
maybe that's his best ever world
championship match now
is that the level we're seeing from
magnus here now
um i don't know it's difficult to say i
mean is that his best ever
i'm not entirely sure obviously it was
the defining moment in his career
when he became world champion i had the
honor to be there in
india calling the uh the action uh with
uh my good friend tanya sachdev who's
also doing some commentary
for this tournament of course part of
the play magnus group
uh so tanya and i and susan polgar and
ramesh were there
um teaching which was sorry commentating
rather
uh it was great and uh i was actually
there earlier in the year when he won
the candidates tournament in london as
well so it was a
2013 really was his his year and
he hasn't been knocked off the top since
in terms of level was it his best chess
i mean it was of course very impressive
i don't think vichy
in that world championship was um
uh aggressive enough i think he was a
little too passive and gave it a bit too
easily to magnus
i think magnus has probably performed
better in other world championships
although they've all been very close if
we think of kayaking and
if we think of fabi um maybe
maybe that was his best uh but i
whatever way you
you look at it what we're seeing now is
um
magnus carlsen basically in fifth gear
and
as as anybody would say who knows chess
if he continues playing like this he
there there is no real match in this
tournament he's not really
making huge blunders he's playing some
really fun chess as well it looks like
he's enjoying his chess um
and uh i don't see anybody stopping him
at this point all right well finally
lauren sanjivanka should we push him on
the spot as we always do with the
question of the day
let's do it so okay we are asking
everyone at home what skills do you have
or perhaps aspire to have that you are
grand master level at
is that a question to me yeah is the
question
what skills do i have yeah or that i
aspire to have which one
that you're well it can be aspire to
have well we do know that is chess
that's my life so do you have any other
skills than chess then lauren's
that you're you're must level yeah uh
i'm i'm a i'm a grand master
but does it have to be to do with chess
or just life in general oh yeah
so for me for example it's like sudoku
oh goodness
uh i am a grand master
level um
[Music]
this is this is this is like 5 p.m right
so let's
let's uh i would say i'm a grandmaster
level
homemade lasagna maker
so if you guys ever make it over to
berlin if
a leg if we ever get international again
and you do on-site tours
and you're in berlin you're more than
welcome i'll do a veggie lasagna a meat
lasagna
whatever you want bitter salad glass of
wine lovely dublin oh i'm already
looking forward to it
i need to set up a date lauren yeah
you're all divided
oh thank you wow i'm looking forward to
it thank you so much for joining us and
inviting us lawrence
thank you very much guys keep up the
good work obviously big fan as i said
last time you're doing a great job and
exciting chess to come let's see what
happens yeah absolutely thanks laurence
thank you very much all right that was
exciting and i'm looking forward to
lasagna
any other great skills out there yeah
there are certainly some great skills uh
we have a tweet from paul
r who says i guess i achieved a gm
skill in tennis wow i've been playing
for eight to nine years now and these
are my achievements although it says not
many
but it's actually two trophies which is
two trophies more than i have than in
tennis
it's actually um it's quite amazing and
that's always something
and we also have a skill from josh who
says his gm skill
is having the black belt at 11 and his
second dan belt at 13. wow
sadly i don't train anymore but at 21 i
like to think i still
got it so certainly fantastic fantastic
gm skill in karate and then vlad
montine says his gm skill is cutting
cherry tomatoes
you know as someone who cooks
occasionally i can see that is a very
very impressive skill
absolutely absolutely sniff that and
very inspiring yes and uh peter
ellig has a skill and a proposition for
david
he says my gm skill is skiing i'd love
to trade david skiing and chess lessons
he did a great job on his first lesson
but wow just look at that landscape
you're very good at skiing kaya as well
no
norwegian level yeah just okay oh okay
and
then also we have len who says that
having
laser-like vision is a grand master
skill curly hair
not with standing and yeah
those are that those are some gm skills
and of course the quiz of the day that
we're asking is what skills do you have
that you are grand master level
at and you can tweet your answer using
the hashtag
chesschamps we love to see them we
love even more when you show us your
pictures and one lucky winner wins
things mini device fantastic join in now
let's take a look at the results from
round
two before we're heading into round
three minus carlson and
aronian played a draw magnus with a win
in the next one we'll be
uh through um lavonna wesley so beat
alireza varusia so a
draw is enough for him in the next game
naponnayachi now two wins that means he
only needs a draw
in the next one aneesh geary was able to
beat my saint vagina
so that's going to be a super intense
fight
all right let's take a look at the game
that we will follow now in
round three it will be
the game between magnus carlton and
levon aronian
because it could be over after this one
and we do know
that uh the volaronian he has to win
this game
yeah levono ronin he will have the white
pieces but so far
it hasn't gone well for him that we see
their head-to-head scores in the
champions chess tour so far and magnus
carson
he's got those four wins three of them
have come in this quarter-final
level on iranian yeah it's last chance
saloon it's do or die time
he needs to win at all costs but i do
love these situations but
because we always get very interesting
chess when one player
has to win the game and that is the
situation for
level neronia now with the white pieces
so definitely he could have the chances
in magnus crawls and he's been looking
very good so far in the sports final
but a little bit of unfocused maybe
in that last game sometimes that has
meant a downhill for him
what do you expect from the world
champion i think that the last game was
just a blip
i don't think uh i don't think that will
affect carlson too much
he knows that this is the big one always
when you have the black pieces
you just have this increased kind of
awareness this increased
sensitivity to any danger and magnus
he's looked good with the black pieces
so far he won their first game
their first clash of the day with black
and
um he will want to just take
all of the fun out all that all of the
joy
out of ironian's game at an early stage
if you can
alright well we are waiting for the game
to start we do see that the three other
games have started and there we are
is it a winning opening we're seeing we
will see kaya
it is a king's pawn opening levon
aronian he started every game
he's had with the white pieces against
magnus in this quarter final with
these moves um it hasn't brought him any
luck so far
but we will see okay the berlin defense
playing it
david said it he's gonna try to kill the
position
right from the word get go away from the
word start and
you can see the moves are coming thick
and fast
but having said that you know we did see
napoli actually
absolutely obliterate the hirokara
nakamura in the berlin
yeah so this opening is called the
berlin wall because it's so solid it's
so hard to break down
um that being said the berlin wall did
eventually fall and
sometimes this opening with black it is
possible to crack it
from time to time this opening with
black became
popular at the top level when vladimir
kramnik used it to great effect against
gary kasparov in 2000 to win the world
title
uh magnus carlsen as well has used this
opening with black
um in matches such as that one we
mentioned earlier with lawrence in 2013
in the world championship against aladd
that being said both players are
actually experts
in this opening as black so it's
interesting to see levon go for it with
the white pieces i very
very rarely see him um aronian on the
white side
of this opening normally i see him with
the black pieces and i noticed that one
thing has also happened that ivanka
you said aronia should avoid the queens
are already off
it's move ten the queens have
disappeared you said levon aronian
needed to avoid this one
yeah i mean we've seen magnus be
incredibly impressive
in the in-game we've seen magnus fall
in dubois hands when the queens were on
the board
he fell victim to a checkmate um yeah i
i
just yeah i i think it's a
slightly risky play kind of approach by
lavon to actually go into this kind of
territory right approach
i mean i would never even dream of going
into the same game against magnus carson
in a must-win situation because the
drawing margins are so high
right i mean that's so solid
that's kind of like the traditional
methodology that i would be thinking
about doing i was like okay this is just
too solid
not too many chances here but uh okay
let's assume that lavon has something in
mind
yeah levon for sure he must have
something in mind a very specific idea
but
if we bring up the analysis board the
reason magnus carson is thinking right
now while he wipes his eyes
is because black has so much choice
black can develop this bishop he can
develop his other bishop
um he can just push a pawn this square
this square so much choice for black
no right or wrong and that makes it very
hard for the opponent
to prepare any specific ideas um that's
why i don't like it for
uh levon orronian so much magnus carlsen
his biggest problem
with the black pieces is this king it
looks like it can castle later on but
remember the king has already moved
twice
in this game earlier on it moved it
captured the queen and then it moved
back to where it came from
so the black king despite the fact it's
in the middle right now cannot castle
the rest of the game
that means it's harder for black to get
the rooks in the game if the king is
stuck in the center
so some issues with peace development
for magnus carson apart from that though
it's all fine very solid pawn structure
and the two bishops
that tends to become a factor later on
um if black can maintain those bishops
while lots of other trades happen then
black tends to be doing quite well
so white will be trying to look at the
black king take advantage of it being in
the center and
maybe use his better pawn structure
black having these double pawns
white meanwhile having an extra pawn uh
having a poor majority
on this right half of the board um yeah
this
this end game it's known to be super
solid for black but
magnus carlson he'll still still uh need
to be vigilant
in order to guide this one to safety um
yeah i haven't seen magnus use this
opening for a while actually it normally
tends to be against the very very
top players when he wants to draw like
in the world championship match in 2016
but then was it him or was it sergey
karjakin who all the time sort of
made the berlin wall yeah i mean both of
those players used the berlin wall but
in 2013 2014 against anand that's when
the berlin was
uh kind of uh magnus's main weapon
against karyakin he started playing
other openings such as the martial
defense uh the martial attack
um when it's slightly more competitive
so
combative um yeah magnus carlsen
he's going back to what he knows best uh
his old opening repertoire okay he
retreats his knight this is actually my
favorite move
um black going back with the knight
clearing the light squares for black's
light squared bishop to
jump out a bit later on but iranian he
replies immediately
i've had this position uh before against
some very strong players
and yeah it's just so solid for black
expect to see black's knight jump out to
a different square
um yeah magnus just
taking his time he knows there's plenty
of options for black on every move
so are you going to let us in and some
grand master secrets david and tell us
what you have prepared here
what would you play as black okay let's
bring up the board i'm going to give
away some uh
some secret analysis that i've done in
the past um so
with black's last move bringing the
knight back you have cleared the
path for this bishop but at the moment
there's nowhere really great for it to
go so there's two moves that i would
consider
um either bringing the knight back to
where it came from actually trying to
trade pieces trying to exchange white
tonight
um but there is i think there's a trap
in this position
the other move i would think about is
bringing the knight this way
this is probably the one i would choose
attacking this white pawn and it's
slightly awkward to defend
how does white defend this pawn you
don't really want to move this rook
again you don't want to bring it back
where it came from
in the direction it came from at least
you don't really want to push your pawn
at this early stage with white because
suddenly black will develop
with tempo that means black creates a
threat and gets some peace development
you can bring your bishop out
attacking this rook next move black's
rook will jump uh into the game
um this is a bit awkward for white to
deal with so the move i would play is
bring my knight to this square okay
magnus first
does the i mean same idea uh the other
move order he tries the other move first
he brings the bishop out attacking this
rook
i expect to see live on a ronin and kick
this bishop back the bishop will
drop back either to this square or this
square um but then black will
centralize his rook does this move a
surprise to you david because just
looking at the
looking at the database i can see there
haven't been too many games you know
there's
many many many games in the lines that
you just showed just now but here
maybe at the most seven yeah um
this last move by magnus carlsen um
probably is effect uh it's just
influenced by the fact that levon aroni
was playing instantly up to this point
so he decided to bring his bishop out
and surprise levon and get him out of
his homework
um so it does look like black bishop is
losing a lot of time but there is an
idea he has cleared the path
for that black rook um later on i think
he'll have the same idea that i
mentioned
just a moment ago he will try and bring
his knight out to activate this bishop
which is kind of
kind of boxed in at the moment um so
yeah lots of
um kind of lots of ideas for black it's
just putting them together
in the right order meanwhile um yeah
level of ronin he needs to develop
quickly because as we mentioned if
pieces start to get traded
if black's able to keep his bishop pair
uh both the bishops on the board then
black is doing quite well
okay there we see okay magnus um does
retreat his bishop so
um for those of you at home who are
wondering why uh magnus moved his bishop
out
allowed levon to push a pawn and then
dropped his bishop back it looks like
magnus has lost a move
um but the move that levon ironian has
gained
from that maneuver is a pawn move which
doesn't necessarily improve his position
it does maybe weaken a diagonal uh
towards the white king
that magnus will try and utilize a bit
later on
very very deep stuff here um no doubt
the players have studied
similar ideas before this berlin wall
opening i mean i dread to think how many
hours i've spent in my life studying it
um i remember i had a book when i was
young on the berlin wall by john cox
and i used to kind of uh pour over it
just
by uh by candle light almost just day
and day
and yeah day in day out when i was first
learning the opening because i think i
was
13 years old and i had no coach and i
decided on my own
for some reason i mean i don't advise
kids to learn this opening because it's
too dry but
i decided myself i needed something more
solid and um that was how i learnt
yeah i have a question for you did you
actually do
your studying with a chess chessboard or
were you
too lazy or clever enough to just simply
just visualize the moves
um i i mean i'm lazy in general but that
at that time i think i was quite
disciplined when i was 13 14 i always
had a chessboard with me
i used to pack a chessboard in my uh
luggage going to every tournament
these days i i'd rather have some
clothes or some chocolate in there but
um but yeah in those days my
visualization
has always been quite good but it's been
maybe uh
it's improved because i uh put things on
the board originally it was quite
interesting no you know because i was
talking to another grand master and he
said that his visualization skills were
amazing
because as a kid he used to love reading
chess books but he was too
lazy to pick up the board and so he
followed absolutely everything in his
head
um i i kind of grew up with computers so
i tried to do everything on the computer
okay um i i wasn't very good at reading
books
and uh i mean what i like to do with
books is i just love to
i'm a bit of a magpie i just read one
chapter read you know i think this is
amazing
maybe read four chapters and then before
i know i've picked up another book and
i'm like wow this this book is going to
take me all the way to grandmaster level
and i read four chapters and then i've
lost interest and then i go on to
another book
um but what happens if that fifth
chapter that was it's ridiculous
isn't it i don't know why i do this i
mean
i have to set myself the concrete goal
of like chat
you know finish one chapter per day then
then i can do things but
my natural instinct is just to have to
jump around yeah which is uh not ideal i
i
don't do different things work for
different people so maybe uh maybe it
works for you but uh yeah
are you still aiming to um become a
grand master
yonko is that or well it was actually my
uh
my ambition before the lockdown happened
then i i hired a trainer i was working
with some people
and i was making some radical changes
and working like i'd never worked before
um
because when you when you do this you
often go through a period of adjustment
where you get used to these changes that
you're making and you get used to kind
of like the focus and
everything and so actually my rating
dipped down to the lowest it's ever been
and i lost quite a lot of points and
then coronavirus struck and
i was like what can i do i have no
chance to gain back those rating points
that
i really want to gain and are you
actually then kind of anxious
for when over the board uh chess resumes
and to see
the level you're at because i guess it's
not easy to compare it
completely to what you're doing online
yeah i mean i'm definitely anxious to
kind of
have over-the-board chess resume there's
still a few important tournaments that i
have in my calendar especially those to
do with women's tournaments because
that's going to take you to the next
level yeah
um like for instance there's talk about
there's a big
grand swiss grand swiss that's going to
happen where the hundred of the best
women
like battle it out to be in the
candidates
so you know i i i if i if that
goes ahead and i do get a spot in that
that top hundred women then i'm
definitely will be there
to fight for my place in the candidate
so yeah
exciting times ahead hmm yeah you'll
have that trance ivanka you'll be yeah
you have that chance too yeah you know i
have a daily training with uh
with david who's giving me lots of
insight and i must say
following these uh top players in the
world it's very inspiring and especially
when i'm looking at these
games and i'm trying not to use my
engine okay occasionally i can see the
bar and so that
that's a big spoiler alert for me but
you know it is it is good good practice
to try to predict and try to
think of what about what these players
are going to play
and uh yeah but i mean it's it's super
exciting you know to have that
possibility to be a
a dm a grand master or something yeah
such an exclusive club to be a part of
yes yeah yeah definitely and uh yeah
it's interesting to have that like a
grand master skill at life yeah i do
i do really like our quiz of the day
yeah i do too and
yeah i'd happily trade my grandmaster
title for
lawrence's skill of being able to cook
cooking is easy it takes time
what's your specialty then david my
specialty dish yeah
an omelette i don't know nothing too
complicated
um okay meanwhile levon aronian has
pushed a pawn
um that's just uh kind of uh planning in
advance he just wants to gain a bit of
space
maybe that pawn is going to continue
pushing um a slightly mysterious one for
me
i'm not sure it's the most useful move
right now but it does keep the white
options open
so um later on white will decide where
to place his bishop
where to maybe start start advancing his
king
i would have been very tempted to start
advancing my king with white or uh bring
a bishop out but okay levon
pushes a pawn i've noticed that most of
the top ground masters they play this
move sooner or later so
um i won't fault it meanwhile magnus
brings his knight back to where it came
from a few moves ago but now he is just
trying to
get rid of those knights i did mention
earlier if you can keep the two bishops
on the board as black
in this type of position then um then
you tend to be
doing pretty well especially if the
rooks disappear as well later on um
yeah i think good move by magnus carlsen
i should also mention when i was 11
years old i
had the chance to play kramnik who's the
world champion at the time and
in a series of blitz matches and i knew
he would play this opening against me it
was kind of his
calling card at the time and i when i
had the white pieces i did some training
matches i kind of planned in advance
but i didn't understand the subtleties i
let him keep the bishop pair
until late in the game and okay i would
have lost to him anyway he was too
but yeah that came back to haunt me in
this exact opening so especially black's
light square bishop
you can um maybe if we bring up the
analysis board um we can see
why levon aronian actually retreated
this knight um he
did not go for this night trade because
especially this light square bishop is
not challenged
white earlier had traded his light
square bishop so this bishop is the most
important piece right now and it has
targets um this pawn is always going to
be weakness later in the game
you can imagine this pawn becoming a
weakness as well later on that's how i
lost those games to vladimir kramnik he
traded every single piece off
but he left himself with this light
squared bishop and that's what cost me
those games
um that's why levon aronian in the
current position as well refused to
trade knights he dropped his knight back
meaning that this bishop can't reach its
dream squares right now
all of these ideas they come up time and
time again in this opening now i expect
magnus to bring his bishop out
maybe give a check or to bring his rook
across it's time to activate some pieces
for magnus
yeah now i love what you said about the
light square and bishop because this is
like the
epitome of secret knowledge of really
understanding the position because often
like you said you'll play this position
and you just be like okay i'll just do
this this and make some trades
level and then you have an issue like
the light squared bishops suddenly
become a monster
and you end up losing without a chance
yeah and okay there's been some progress
here we had a little check
and the white king has taken a step
towards the center
and big maybe a big decision here for
magnus carlsen would you give a check
with your knight here ivanka
or would you not get tempted for black
no i don't think i would give a night
check there i think i i would uh
just concentrate on development
yes i mean there's one issue that does
consume me and i think it
always concerns every player when
they're playing on the black side of
this berlin
it's basically what how are you going to
move the dark squared bishop once it's
attacked
so if i if i make the most natural move
to me which was sim
simply to step forward with the king
just to connect the two rooks
then white will challenge my bishop
and then oh my goodness i might have
big big problems yeah so if you step
forward with the king to connect these
rooks
as you say ivanka there's maybe two
issues here one is that the knight will
step forward harassing this bishop which
doesn't have too many good squares but
maybe
the more urgent problem is that there is
a check in the position
and the black king might even have to
step back um that's why magnus carson
okay
first he pushes a pawn so he's clamping
down on the right side of the board he's
stopping
any potential pawn push kicking away his
strong knight so
this is a really nice move this pawn
push um solidifying his knight on this
square
it's going to be almost impossible for
white to kick back that knight to remove
it
the other move i think magnus was
considering in this position is to drop
his knight forward giving check
and many people might be tempted to do
this because now you have two bishops
against two knights
but you lose a bit of time with black
and actually the knights are
pretty decent in these types of
positions white would gain time against
this bishop the bishop drops back and
gain a bit more time against the other
bishop look at these rooks now
lining up so magnus carson playing what
i think is a really nice move
just pushing his pawn forward you could
even imagine this pawn dropping further
forward
and causing some chaos instead the night
drops forward and the bishop drops back
yes yes like at the moment to trade the
the night for the bishop has said this
has gone
actually so uh definitely very very
interesting kind of
opening so far like black is in a shell
kind of like really trying to hold and
restrain
white's activity meanwhile white is
simply just trying to make some
improvements so it's very much a
reactionary
um opening you don't really tend to do
anything right as well as black
you're always just reacting yeah and uh
doesn't necessarily matter with
connecting the rooks that doesn't matter
what i've learned is that just make some
moves
yeah keep everything protected exactly
frustrate all your opponent's plans
and uh seize space with pawns in order
to protect
your your knight yep and
the other thing i should mention about
these types of of positions um these
types of
queenless middle games that arise from
the berlin wall is that
computers are not to be trusted the main
reason that vladimir kramnik became
world champion
is because he used this opening um as
black
every time he played gary kasparov in
that world championship match
and gary he was famous for using
computers um to his benefit but
computers they struggle to understand
these types of positions
they often give white a small advantage
here we see that white has a 0.3
advantage
according to the computer but actually
it doesn't show any plans
um computers struggle to come up with
the right plans or very non-human plans
at least
and black's position because it has it
because it is so solid it has no real
weaknesses
um it often becomes easier to play if
white oversteps
so sometimes players um when i play this
opening is black
if my opponents have studied with a
computer and they've memorized some
lines
sometimes they'll reach a position and
they suddenly think oh they suddenly
realize there's nothing else to do
i've followed the computer i've pushed
everything forward i've committed myself
but what next
and um yeah computers i think even
though they're so strong nowadays
they still struggle sometimes in these
types of positions
yeah you know actually i have to show
you guys
one picture it's by stephen wright he
earlier tweeted and entered into our
quiz of the day competition
and he said that his grandmaster skill
was looking after his sick dog
and he later tweeted here's a picture of
louie
dressed up as a cowboy for halloween
yeah that's so adorable and uh i also
have a question for you david
yes it's actually yeah it's a very
personal question it says
it's from ibrahim and he says what is
your score against magnus carlsen
he's just curious i mean
in official games i think we've had a
few draws
three or four draws and i lost the last
two games that we've played um over the
board actually one of my favorite games
was in 2009 in the london chess classic
when
i played magnus he was number one in the
world at the time and i was
i think i was okay i was a grandmaster
but i was under 2600 so i was the bottom
seed in the tournament he was the top
seed
and we played one of the longest games
i've ever played at one point i actually
blundered a piece in one move and he
didn't see it
but um yeah that was one of the craziest
most enjoyable games i've ever played
um we've also played each other many
many times like friendly online
over the board blitz games and there
he's quite a lot ahead as well
i think a few months ago during the
lockdown the first lockdown in the virus
we played online and he won
i think around 45 points to my 15 so it
was like
there's no training because you're there
you then went on to win
the hastings online you want van ratty
online
we're speaking of banrati we do have to
wish all our irish viewers a happy saint
patrick's day yes patrick's day
and your dress is chosen for this
occasion isn't it it is
i deliberately chose something green
just uh in honor
yeah it's quite funny because now that
i'm living in norway that i've become
even more homesick for things
and celebrations and this year i mean
celebrations bring them on well happy st
patrick's days i i hope you get to
celebrate
at least a little bit with your families
and yeah
not too much guinness a little bit is
lovely
yeah okay so meanwhile um we
do see levon aronian i really like what
he's doing actually right now
look at those white knights they are
finding good squares they are looking
towards outposts
um and the other thing that white has
done over the last few moves is he's
kind of initiated this trade of dark
squared bishops and usually
long term this does favor white you have
to time it correctly you don't want to
allow black pieces to get too active
while you trade those dark squared
bishops but remember
bishops work best as a pair so what
level neronian is doing he's just
put those bishops looking at each other
he's going to say okay
at the right moment i'll trade those
guys off and you will no longer be with
that pair of bishops
you will just be stuck with the bad king
as black and the worst pawn structure
yeah and by worst pawn structure perhaps
we should
bring up the board and show them that
basically white's dream is to eliminate
all the pieces on the board
and the whole point is that david take
it away
what is going to be the winner the
winner will be this pawn
if you divide the board in half you see
that white has this four
versus three advantage on this side of
the board
it's easy to make if you imagine all the
pieces disappearing i know it's
difficult but if you visualize
all of the pieces disappearing or the
pawns remaining
it's easy for white to make a past pawn
in a king and pawn end game white will
win
because simply especially this pawn will
be the winner
black on the other side of the board has
a four versus three advantage but if you
look at black's pawns here
um especially these guys they are
doubled so actually in a king and
pawning game
in a pure end game like that with no
pieces on the board it's just impossible
to create a passport
these two are not necessarily better
than whites one um so long
long long term white is uh winning
but there's a long way to go before that
and um
talked about long too much and uh magnus
carlton did not have a long think and
he's traded
pieces um i'm not so sure i like that i
you remember i highlighted the fact that
black had his light squad bishop as a
potential trump later on in the game
uh meanwhile though his idea magnus is
to try and trap this white rook
it's actually lacking squares in the
middle of the board magnus carson with
two ideas to take this pawn
and to maybe push forward to take this
rook um this one is getting
tense already i really like what levon
aronian's doing
um if he can somehow save his rook then
white has a big advantage well now we've
got the board up maybe we can look at
ways of saying
okay well we don't have to because
lavonne aronian has provided the answer
for us he's just
going to attack the knight now what's
going to happen
if there is a counter attack though
once you know black says you attack my
knight i attack your rook
i think there's actually only one move
for white to keep the advantage here and
it's a really really nice move
uh why should just this rook attacked
why should you step forward
sacrificing this rook on a square it can
be captured
but now white would jump forward and the
key thing is that it's check so when
black loses time moving his king
white will capture the knight in the
center and knight and bishop they will
outmatch a rook so white would be
winning in this case so after white
would step his rook forward
i think it's time for magnus to move
this night and um
he would be in a bit of trouble okay he
decides not to do this
instead he just retreats his knight
immediately but this is a great same
time
i mean we saw it again in we saw it in
the second game that you know he wasn't
necessarily the most precise it wasn't
actually critical because the game ended
in a draw
he was never in any serious danger but
here we see again the knight steps
forward
gets kicked back night retreats
yep small small things yup butterfly
effect
yeah a series of small um i mean this is
what you have to do is white you'll
never crash through immediately you'll
never give checkmate
you'll never immediately kind of create
a past pawn and win the game
but you just have to kind of collect
this series of small advantages and you
hope that they add and build up
um towards something a bit bigger and um
here
white still has the better pawn
structure white has the more active
pieces um
i would be okay white first has to deal
with his bishop i would be tempted to
just retreat that
i would not go for the trade right now
because actually black's dart square
bishop is a bit locked in it doesn't
have
an amazing future so i would retreat my
bishop right now and just
ask magnus what are you gonna do
remember black's king cannot castle it's
already moved
so it just gets in the way of the black
rooks and um
there's some problems to solve well
there you go and this is this is the
questions
this is what magnus is saying okay fine
you retreat the bishop but now
there is going to be a rook trade uh
would you take that rook or would you
just pile on
so that's what uh mag lavon has chosen
to do he has
doubled his rooks and i guess after the
trades
it's all going to hinge on how
lavon can carry on improving his
position i mean i think that lavon has
played this perfectly yeah it's a risky
opening choice because
this opening is known for being so
drawish but i mean
he is gaining i wouldn't say significant
but a kind of a a little bit of an
advantage yeah i mean it's lots of small
things that just add up to one bigger
thing and
for magnus i think the problem is how to
activate that rook in the corner
that black rook i mean it wants to
somehow leapfrog over the black king
to trade itself off but it's not easy to
do that magnus
trying to lengthen the um the scope for
that black rook by pushing a pawn
i would just ignore that if i were live
on ironian i would start pushing some
more i mean
pushing some other pawns quite pro quite
possibly in
which pawns would you push would you
push the one that's in front of the king
yep i would push the pawn in front of my
king right now
yeah and he's done that uh uh we're very
good with the crystal ball today aren't
we
it's logical as well um not only do you
threaten to push that pawn even further
up to kick away the black knight but you
also just create a square
for the king um white's king might step
up
actually i expect that right now white's
king to step up one square
um often the king that can get to the
center of the board quickest in the end
game
i mean yeah we'll often win the game and
maybe
it is the round for comebacks it is
looking uh quite good for levon ronin in
this game and look at on the bottom
the bar slightly over to cara nakamura's
side he does need
um a win in that game to hopefully
or hope have hopes of taking it to tie
breaks and ali reza bruce as well i can
see on the bar
slightly over to his side and he as well
uh
needs to uh to win uh both of the two
last games actually to take it to tie
breaks
wow yeah i just took a sneak peek at
both those games
crazy stuff anything could happen in
both of those ones
so although nakamura and furuzee have
small advantages
anything could change everything can
change in one minute
exciting round and uh it is
looking good for a living aronian is it
is it so good that you could almost
predict a win for him or is it
far away it's still far away the win but
every move he's slowly growing his
advantage he's just
he's pushed all the white pawns he's
getting ready for that potential race
um end games they're all about races
it's all about creating those past pawns
he's trying to kind of just suffocate uh
magnus carlson magnus
how many times has he moved that night
uh maybe this is one for the viewers try
and count how many times he's moved his
knight
uh in this game but magnus he's been
dancing around with his knight
that black knight still hasn't found a
great square though uh meanwhile look at
levon he's just protecting everything
he's activated the white king white's
rook white's knight bishop they're all
perfectly placed right now
the more i look the more i look at it
the more i think actually magnus is
in big trouble and if levon wins this
his opening choice will look inspired
i think he was just kind of playing on
the fact that magnus was
maybe a bit too eager to force things
too eager to get to the finishing line
yeah make that draw yeah absolutely and
good
good opening preparation i mean he's
definitely chosen the right strategy
i mean i'm kind of curious about lavon
aronia because he has
performed performed actually
tremendously in previous events and then
and then now it has looked a little bit
shaky um
okay not not taken away from magnus but
we do actually have
a question from max curie he says is
biorhythm an issue in chess
and it's hint he likens it says it seems
like some days
max lose cannot lose a game other days
he's a serial blunderer
and i've seen that happen to the pros
too um what do you think david
bio rhythm yeah i had to go ahead and
work for me that was a new word for me
too
so it's it's a pseudo-scientific idea
that our daily lives are significantly
affected by rhythmic cycles with periods
of exactly 23
28 and 33 days wow wow
yeah it was it was deep for me too i was
hoping that you'd have the answer
i mean i wouldn't be surprised i mean
often results are affected by
just your kind of state of mind your
happiness your routine
um if you've got something kind of on
your mind if you've got something going
on
that you're not happy with then it will
affect your results it will affect your
game
um and yeah i i share that uh sentiment
max
there are some things i feel like some
days i feel unbeatable i can't explain
it and i wish i could i could wish i
could bottle up that feeling and
sell that magic ingredient but um
i saw an interesting article about this
that you should actually
focus on uh your results on and study
your results
according to what time you've played the
game so if you've played the game in the
morning and you kind of look at the
pure statistics and you're like okay i
do really really well in the morning
you should only play online chats in the
morning
and uh i was like okay i have never ever
thought like that at all yeah
i mean i um i mean the reason my online
results have been quite good lately
because okay firstly i've switched to a
mouse rather than a touch pad but
yeah i've been much more disciplined
with when i play
and how much i play in one go i used to
just play hours and hours a day without
thinking about my body clock or think
without thinking about nutrition and
all that stuff but yeah nowadays i only
play
if i'm feeling fresh feeling good i've
already slept eight hours um
yeah i mean i'm not sure about biorhythm
but definitely
just being in a good place yes helps the
trust results yeah and if you have any
questions or you want to share any
pictures with us
please tweet us using the hashtag
chesschamps
we really do love it when you join in
the fun and joining the conversation
and there's been a few advances actually
in the position because we can see that
lavon aronian's king
well it has made a space walk and is now
looking mighty impressive there on the
right side
yeah that king has its running shoes on
um the white king is
trying to just kick back the black rook
but also support the advance of the
white pawns
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see um this king
doing a great job right now it has
forced the black rook to a worse square
but you still need to find a new plan
for levon aronian
because ideally you want to push this
pawn forward but if you push it forward
now
it does allow a capture in the center of
the board you lose protection of this
pawn that is why i level on irony and
he's trying to insist
on pushing his rook up to defend this
pawn but we've seen it from magnus
carson before a very
in a very similar position he's attacked
this rook trying to kick it away
and when that rook moves back the knight
drops back so mac just begging for a
move repetition
um what i would do here for lev on a
ronin in a few moments time
he can repeat the position first once or
remaneuver slightly but what i would
recommend is rerouting this knight bring
this knight
back and no matter what black does i
mean black's lacking moves already
no matter what black does just jump the
knight into this square keep an eye on
this pawn
and now re-route the king to the center
kings love to be in the middle of the
board
the king will defend this pawn and then
the pawns will start running
um i think this is the plan if levon
aronian finds it that will give him a
huge advantage
meanwhile magnus just trying to make
life as difficult as possible for him
trying to harass his pieces he gives a
check white's king has to step back um
yeah level one's in control magnus is
just in kind of damaged limitation mode
he's just trying to make uh well just
trying to maybe set some traps just
trying to um discourage levon aronian
from finding the right plan
oh i really did like your plan of
rerouting the night because that wasn't
that was the move that i wanted to play
so anything that coincides with that
but i agree with you david i mean he has
to find a like an
orchestrated way of using every single
piece on the board just to advance those
pawns and just to kind of squash black
yep um black if you notice magnus
carlsen's last
what is it now almost 10 moves he's done
nothing he's just moving up and down up
and down he's waiting
um he's just kind of curled up into a
ball and said to everyone
i bet you can't get through but um levon
okay what i do like about what levon is
doing is he's just
also maneuvering slowly improving his
pieces step by step
and playing quickly magnus down down to
two minutes
and um this position is so hard to
defend for black when you're low on time
i mean it's human instinct as well to
lash out to do something
um it's not human instinct to sit and
wait so it's going to be difficult for
magnus carson
he has less than two minutes on the
clock now um
a difficult position on the board bad
situation on the clock
the magnus that we've been praising so
much in these quarterfinals
not really had it uh he's not really
shown it in this game at least
yes well it's kind of a kind of
continuation of what's happened in game
two because game two we saw him
hesitating
using a lot of time on the clock uh but
there he had the white pieces now he has
the black pieces
and well that usually follows with some
kind of
uncomfortableness when uh when you're
kind of
taking those slight inaccuracies when
you're making those bad moves
yeah and i know we were laughing about
the food and the salad he was eating and
everything but
it does feel like somehow it's just
slowed him down and uh maybe it's
just that digestion but he's um yeah
he's
lost his rhythm and wow oh okay uh
magnus carlsen
he i mean he's sacrificing a porn he's
got an idea in mind but i think that
idea is faulty
i don't think it quite works and there's
actually almost
a winning uh idea here for level iranian
look at that
stockfish the computer says white only
has one move not just one move to win
but also one move not to lose
white has to play bishop takes knight
right now um that black knight in the
centre of the board giving check
white has to take it um levon ironian is
it a human move
is it something he will the most obvious
okay but it's the follow up okay okay
let's let's put it up on the board and
let's show it because it's looking okay
we're going to see it
so bishop takes that how does miners
react to this yeah this is his reaction
he has
pushed his pawn to attack lavon
aronian's rook
now what is the way for lavon to escape
this yeah the good thing for lev level
neronian as we see
below the players there as well he has
three good moves and
all of them maintain the advantage um
one move may be better than the others
but it's not the most obvious one um i
think there are two other moves which
maintain the advantage
um or a good enough winning advantage um
which are much more natural which are
much more human so
here white's rook is trapped but he can
just ignore it he can just
move back uh the white bishop and just
say to black okay you can take my rook
but those white pawns in the center
are going to be so strong they're going
to be scary you can't deal with them
as black i think magnus carlsen i did
mention it he lost patience
it's really hard to just sit still and
hope for the best um
okay level of running he finds the best
move wow
um yeah i mean now look at those two
white central pawns
they're so advanced black has an
advantage in terms of
rook versus knight but the black rook
it's on a bad circuit it doesn't have
any active squares any open lines
all levon aronia needs to do now is
retreat his bishop
um he can even trade those bishops off
to be honest i think
the white knight combined with those
white central pawns should
overpower uh the black rook what would
you do here ivanka retreat that bishop
trade
um i would think i would retreat the
bishop yeah so i would treat it just to
kind of keep
an extra piece to attack because those
central white pawns they're amazing
and when they go forward i want there to
be extra pieces to back it up
yeah and i think both of these players
they will sense that white is winning
but
there isn't i mean it's not over there's
still some life and there's still some
hope for magnus carson
because if somehow the black rook does
get active if you imagine the black rook
kind of going on a long journey and kind
of getting behind white's position
then brooks i mean the rook will simply
be dominant and the rook will win the
game
so levon aronian not only does he have
to keep control of the position
but he has to make sure that that rook
um doesn't
enter um okay levono running he's ahead
on time slightly so that
is another reason he should win this
game um but he has to keep his rhythm up
he's found some
incredible ideas he's found all the
right moves um i can't thought any of
his moves actually live on a rooney in
this game but
uh he needs to keep it up what a
comeback it seems to be by lavon
haronian and we did see on the bottom of
the screen maximum vagina grabbing
lennish geary they played a draw
and that means that mvl he has to win
the last game to take it to tybrix
exciting stuff all right we have another
move yep levon aronian
as we predicted he keeps his bishop um i
did notice the computer wanted to trade
those bishops off but i think that would
have
um increased the risk factor so dropping
his bishop back
um yeah very logical look at why it's
kind of the four central squares of the
whole board they're occupied by white's
pieces that's a really nice formation
and those two white pawns leading the
charge that's how it should be in any
battle
your foot soldiers go first your kind of
cavalry
and artillery goes afterwards yes um
yeah this is perfect set up for love on
ironian
yeah um magnus okay pushing the rook
forward one square he's just trying to
stop
the further advance of white's pawns but
i think that's just the
uh temporary yeah i mean just look at
the black crook it's not really doing
anything it's on the corner of the board
no mobility no nothing and everything is
going to hinge on those
white central pawns so how would you uh
how would you play this position with
the white pieces would you
simply improve your pawns or would you
just go
now good question ivanka difficult
question
um if we bring up the analysis yeah we
can see um just the reason white is
better
material is level white has a knight and
two pawns for a rook so that actually
that's five points each so material is
level but these two pawns are so strong
um i would try and maneuver first maybe
one idea is to actually just bring the
king round
i know it's a long journey but white's
king if it can come around and it will
support the advance
of white's pawns i'd be tempted as well
to push the king forward
to attack this rook to try and support
the advance of this pawn but black will
kind of stimmy this idea by pushing his
pawn forward and it's not clear
what to do next so what about rerouting
the knight
he does this okay now it's time to
reroute this knight you're right your
banker
um there's no rush as well levanov he
can maneuver
his pieces around before he starts
pushing the one cardinals in here would
be to push these pawns
too soon uh they will just become weak
okay so
i like your idea reroute this knight
somewhere maybe round this way first yes
i wanted to
tickle those pawns on the left side of
the board i wanted to ask them
exactly i wanted to ask them what are
you going to do how are you going to
defend them because the more pawns i can
collect they are well the more winning
it is
and yeah i completely agree with you do
not push those
beautiful central pawns too early so
levon of course
he's actually you know he took a step
forward with his king he took a step
backwards
is this critical um no i think that's
actually quite nice
that i mean he didn't find the right
idea um immediately so he just took a
step back and now he's rerouting his
knight um look at this night move
he just wants to maybe bring his knight
forward put his king in the center this
is what i was
kind of um kind of advocating a few
moves ago
and once this king is in the middle then
it will start being time to push forward
levon erodian taking his time on the
board
maneuvering his pieces to the right
squares and it will just come down to
the fact that this rook
is offside it's not doing anything it's
much worse than white's knight and pawns
um levon aronian still continuing to
play
i mean extremely impressive chess um
the move is back on magnus about to go
under one minute
it's back to a situation where he has to
sit still again and there's just
no productive ideas for magnus he
attacks the white knight that knight
will move
and that knight will jump forward but
black is stuck
yeah he cannot move his rook
i guess he just has to move his king
back and forth back and forth
and uh just hope for the best i mean
sometimes this is okay because
at least it means you're not consuming
time on the clock and
levon is doing everything by the rule
book
he has maximized his bishop his knight
and now the king is in the center
everything is in a beautiful
place this is like the position that you
were talking about kaya
where it's like everything's beautiful
ah so you just don't wanna
yes but you don't win the game by being
beautiful you have to win the game by
more concrete things
so uh david how would you how would you
improve the black position
oh sorry the white position yeah that's
difficult it's so perfect right now why
it's king bishop and knight on perfect
squares
okay i i like that move levon aronian
drops his bishop back
keeping an eye on black's pawn there on
the corner um
yeah you're right you've anchor in order
to win this one you'll have to give up a
bit of control
and that's in practical terms difficult
thing to do okay
magnus castle maybe this is a helpful
move actually because that pawn
is by itself and uh we actually saw
magnus
win a game against lavon yesterday
because he just was really reckless with
his pawn advances and the pawn was
unsupported
yeah potentially um yeah so magnus now
he's offering a trade of bishops
um i'm not sure levon should go for that
he can go for it he can't take those
bishops off the board but he has to
calculate
perfectly because if the bishops came
off that would be an open line for
black's rook
yeah exactly you want i think you want
the bishop on the board just to keep
control
i think you you hit it on the nail there
because ideally i want to actually pick
up
uh one of my pawns on the right side and
just lift
just push it forward so that so that
there's a wall of three girls a kind of
kaya nicknamed them mean girls
great analogy a row of mean girls we're
going to cause a lot of problems
yeah if we bring up the analysis board
just while magnus has a quick think um
no matter what black does i mean what
can black even do he's completely stuck
kaya you'll love this pawn formation
look at these three white pawns they are
ready
to just march forward to make a new
queen okay magnus carson he's in
desperation mode
uh he didn't want to look at these pawns
he pushes a pawn on the other side
just trying to get his rook active
trying to bring his rook across but i
think it's
too little too late i think it's time to
start pushing these pawns and white
will be winning um i think it's just too
slow for black um you could also if you
want to be kind of a bit clever about it
you could push your pawn forward try and
block the black rook and gain a bit more
time
to get these pawns rolling these guys
these mean girls
they're going to win the game for white
yeah the mean girls they're back
all right that's a scary gang there
[Laughter]
totally is because they're on the black
side of the board by the black side of
the board i mean the top half
i kind of split the board in in quarters
okay
so levon has actually
maneuvered his knight you're not such a
fan of that one ivanka
no i mean i think it's okay i i think
it's no problem whatsoever i just
i liked your idea when you showed me
that one day i was like okay i'm sold
yeah so levonaroni he's done quite a
clever thing he's brought his knight to
the edge of the board not where it wants
to be
but it's going to re-route that knight
is threatening to give a check to the
black king
and actually that knight will control
any possible squares the rook wants to
use
to find an open line um so a nice
maneuver there from levon aronian he's
still
doing perfectly he's still keeping
control that's the most important thing
he hasn't allowed
any counterplay yet so magnus looking
for targets with his pieces
there are none um and if there are no
targets in white's camp white has the
time
has the luxury of just being able to
step forward slowly with his pawns
magnus down to five seconds four three
he doesn't even have his hand under the
mouse
he went down to two seconds there yeah
but that's a very reckless move what's
to stop levon from just capturing that
button saying thank you very much
i think that's pure panic for magnus
okay there was an idea behind it that's
a sneaky idea
here it's a sneaky idea but exactly i
think it's too
little too late um black is threatening
to play rook takes bishop and when the
pawn recaptures
black's corner pawn will drop down and
make a new queen so
for levon aronian just move that bishop
out of the way move it out of the attack
give a check
gain a bit of time as well um yeah and
once that bishop steps forward
i think it's the pawns are simply going
to start running um
yeah there we go and the king has to
move
and okay well that's compensation black
does have the ability now to start
attacking
the white pawn in the corner and
sometimes the the threat is worse than
they execute well it's more dangerous
than the execution because you know it
can be quite scary and
maybe might cause uh lavon to panic yeah
so if if we can maybe just
quickly bring up the board while keeping
an eye on the players um
magnus he only has one trick left in the
position the only saving grace for black
will be to win
this pawn he needs to go after this pawn
with his rook or with his bishop
um if he can get this pawn uh then black
has some counter play black's pawn is
very close to becoming a queen
i don't think he has enough time though
i think it's time for levon aronian
to say time to go for it just push
forward give
check and no matter what black does if
you for example step forward then
the simplest is to just take this bishop
off the board and next move
much your king up and make a new queen
well it's happening it's happening
the check has been played and now i
think well
magnus has gone to the side with his
king so there is no check
for lavon but okay i do like this move
yeah just blocks off the rook very calm
stuff okay
but the tricks continue because magnus
is very insistent that he
is going to win that pawn but uh i mean
uh levon aronian trying to um fight back
by going for black's advanced pawn
i'm not so sure about that one um he's
given up a bit of control in order to
cut out black's counter play maybe levon
was too worried about
carlson's ideas there but okay he's
gambling everything on his far advanced
pawns that night move is tricky
if black captures a poor now with this
king there's a night fork white's knight
will go up
check and capture the black rook um so
i mean this one the only reason levon
aronian hasn't won it already is because
of the clock situation
uh magnus finding tricks to keep this
game going this is uh dramatic and we do
see on the bottom of the screen
wesley so he's ready for the semi-finals
with a win in this game against dolores
varus yeah
yeah he's also ready now for the
semifinals he only needed a draw in that
game
and he's going to face the winner of
this quarterfinal will it be magnus
carlsen or is levon aronian simply
making a huge comeback i mean i two
moves ago three moves ago kaya i would
have said it was a comeback but
suddenly magnus carlsen he's really it
looks like he's tricked aronian
um yeah magnus carson he's activated the
black king he's got rid of some pawns
he's heading closer and closer towards a
draw wow and yeah levon aronian he just
lost control he let black's king get
active
i think he played the right idea just
the wrong order and um
suddenly all magnus needs to do is find
a way to give up the black rook
for all of white's pawns and the game
will be a draw and there we go bishop
takes pawn
what a move giving up the black bishop
but the white knight
should drop off in a moment um it does
look like magnus carlsen
um okay okay it's still
super complicated and there's still some
chances but
magnus now he's going for a trick if
white plays bishop check
yes white will win the rook in the
corner but black will win white central
pawn well we're gonna see it
we're gonna see it um is this a draw
black's king if it gets to the corner of
the board
there's just no way to break through i
think this is a draw magnus shaking his
head actually we are right now joined by
anna pomnyacci
first of all john huge congratulations
on a fantastic coach finals
reaching the semifinals
yeah thank you thank you very much and
we are following the drama now between
levon
and magnus you're going to face the
winner of this quarter violence i would
love to hear your thoughts on what's
going on on the board here
well uh i don't think you need my
expertise here because like
uh every school no every school boy
knows the revelation here yes so that's
that's just a sad moment for lemon who
clearly was winning but
yeah he got tricked
so do you agree david now it's going to
be a draw yeah the black king will head
for the corner and there's no way to
evict it from that square the game is
the draw
the game is going to be in draw and that
means you're going to face magnus in the
semi-finals yeah
how do you feel about that
i don't feel anything special okay yes
that's
that's uh you know that's uh the table
the tournament table uh uh
so the brackets uh so i mean
and madness is gonna you know to face
mike was gonna face me i'm gonna face
magnus so that's
i don't actually know what to eat all
right well
um finally you don't seem too happy even
though you must
uh i mean you had a great day with two
wins against nakamura
played great yesterday as well why are
you not sort of
overly happy here no i mean okay i'm not
very
excited because partially because yeah
first game first two games was too
simple and
easy actually and then the game three
wasn't
uh going a little bit wrong so at some
point i felt like
i gave him some slight chances to come
back but uh i'm not sure if it was like
something pretty serious uh but once you
get the position in which you have to
play okay too
uh this means you played in a in the
wrong way yeah
yeah so maybe maybe nothing critical yes
so this line which appears in the game i
think it's objectively a drawing because
his king is too exposed but i mean
anyway
i was i wasn't too happy about that game
all right well what is it about for you
now then to get ready for
semifinals what will you do to prepare
i don't know just to study his games
study our games study my games
study openings and hopefully
sleep a little it sounds like a good
idea
we wish you all the best in the
semifinals john thanks for joining
thank you thank you
i have to say uh they keep reacting like
these two players if they're not
too happy about a certain aspect in the
game they don't seem too happy even
though it's a great performance by ana
fognachi
yeah fantastic chess from him and chess
players they're just perfectionists
yeah one small error even in the grand
scheme of things even if that error
doesn't matter
um we do dwell on those moves
unfortunately but
yeah napoli actually he's going to give
a great match to carlson all right
and we did see the game with magnus
carlsen wow
what a crazy game levon ronyan it looked
like he was winning
yeah um ah it was eventually a draw
we are right now joined by magnus
crossing ready for semi-finals
congratulations magnus thank you now
could i ask you together with david and
the analysis board to
take us through this final game it was
crazy to us
yeah uh i i guess i was outplayed
at some point and uh i certainly
certainly was
uh was lost uh but
um somehow i managed to to get out of it
uh yeah i'd seen that knight c4 one on
one on the spot but
what could i do yeah by now i guess the
pawns are just running through
um magnus was this game do you think it
was just down to the opening i mean
already around here we thought it was
very difficult for black to even find a
move
um or i mean was that was the opening
kind of affected by the match situation
um
uh yeah sure
um he sort of surprised me there and i i
couldn't
couldn't really find a uh good
good response at all um he surprised you
at what point sorry
no i already early on by playing
rook d1 he sort of confused me with the
move order there
and i mean i i decided just to to
improvise but
i i don't think it was was very good
what i i did probably
while i had the chance i needed to to
take the
the bishop pair or take his other bishop
by checking on e3 because what i got in
the game was just very
very unpleasant and then um
yeah i mean knight d4 was actually um
when i did that was actually just a a
blunder
since i i'd just missed that he could uh
go bishop c5 and take an extra pawn this
way uh i was just
considering f5 probably that is good as
well um
okay so in this position knight d4
yeah yeah it was a miscalculation so
uh that was um yeah it wasn't wasn't
very good
very good um today in general i felt
like i i played played a lot worse than
i did the
the other days um but uh yeah
fortunately i got uh
got the job done so minus right now is
sort of the overwhelming feeling that
you're a little bit disappointed with
this game or
is it that you actually i mean basically
you won two you could have won three
games yesterday
another win today and fantastic
preliminaries
oh sure um i just
need to to sort of pull myself
together tomorrow because i need to play
a bit better than
than i did today but
obviously like the worst moment for me
today was that i could
could have lost lost the game which
meant that i would have had to draw on
demand
uh with with white in the last game so
uh
in that sense it wasn't wasn't bad at
all um
but certainly certainly not quite as
good as the
as the other days i know your father has
said this magnus
is it uh maybe people on my sort of
chess level and
and definitely below your level is it a
common misunderstanding that it's
it's easy to draw on demand is it harder
to draw on the man
than what we think yeah i think
i mean i think it as white it shouldn't
be very
very difficult although i have lost some
games there as well
but yeah it's i think
these most win games are very very tense
for
for both sides and frankly i don't
particularly enjoy being on either side
of them
well it is jana pognati now for you in
the semi-finals that's i mean i'm very
excited about that how do you feel about
it
now it's gonna it's gonna be a good
match-up um
i think he he started out really poorly
in the
preliminaries and then caught fire
towards
the end um and uh
i thought today he was uh he was very
impressive
so uh that's yeah certainly going to be
be a great match up uh magnus you've
known yan
i mean since you were kids i guess and
you've played each other countless times
um are you allowed to give us any
insight into how you'll be approaching
those games
i think uh the um
the most important thing is not to give
him
um
well first of all to pose him some
problems in the openings i guess and
then
not to to let him have sort of easy play
where he can
where you can just uh play quit play
quickly with
little tactical tricks uh all the time
something that he does extremely well
well
finally magnus in the champions chester
have you ever felt
better about your play heading into the
semi-finals
again i would say today wasn't wasn't
great if you'd asked me yesterday no
um but now
overall uh this is even with today this
is obviously a
massive step up from from the last few
tournaments
all right we wish you the best of luck
tomorrow magnus thanks for joining
thank you and
the drama is not over today because it's
still not decided between
these two anish geary and maxim vajiala
gravanishkiri is up by one point
and that means makes the magella grab
he's going to have to win this game
to take it to tie breaks and that is
exciting stuff because anita
has the white pieces so he's going to be
looking
for a very safe position i guess um yeah
usually that would be um annie giri's
approach to play safety first chess but
he's had success yeah with the white
pieces by playing quite
dynamic um quite critical ideas and
not being afraid to uh go for that fight
i don't think any guilty will back down
meanwhile maxine vashtagrav
playing a bit of a risky opening
one that is rarely seen at the top level
he plays the modern
defense that means you just give your
opponent the center you allow your
opponent everything they want they
occupy the center with pawns pieces
and uh black hopes to kind of curl up
into a ball and then counter-attack
at the right time and ishqiri i've seen
him play these types of positions
plenty of times he knows what he's doing
so this is a
risky approach ah this is going to be
fantastic i just have to say after now
talking to
napogniachi and carlson who are both
through to the semi-finals i keep
thinking that
chess players your memory is incredible
but when it comes to results it's like a
goldfish memory
you only remember they both had
fantastic quarter-finals
yeah but they only remember that last
game that they weren't too happy about
and they seemed disappointed
the pain of defeat is far greater than
the joy of a win
well i i think it's also something to do
with the fact that as chess players when
you're playing on the board
you don't allow yourself to get
emotional i mean it's actually a really
bad
sign if you're feeling angry with
yourself or because you can tend to
take it too far and just tilt so you
know
and there is also a danger actually that
when you win a game
and it doesn't mean that much but when
you lose a game or you have a bad moment
they tend to emphasize that
and that's actually a trap that i've
fallen into and that's a way kind of
that's a really bad thing actually
because it's a recipe for falling out of
chat out of love with chess
you got to enjoy every little moment
every little victory that you have
i mean i i personally um just in awe of
the fact that magnus managed to save the
most horrendous position i mean it was
okay yes it was partly to do with lavon
missing
missing a golden opportunity but he
posed the problems
to lavon to get himself into that
situation and
i think deep down he might not show in
the interview but deep down he'll be
feeling yes
i i i definitely saved a lost position
and you get a buzz on that
yeah i mean they're both great champions
yana pomnicci and magnus carlson and
they're just focused i think on the
tasks ahead
they know they've got a difficult
semi-final against each other and um
maybe that's why not they're not kind of
resting on their laurels and being too
um too proud of their achievements they
want more
yeah i remember reading this uh a story
by judith bulger where she said you know
she played this
tournament and she won the most
fantastic game it was absolutely
brilliant you know
the best game she'd ever played in her
life and
you know she was so excited from from
that like victory that she just couldn't
calm her nerves down
when it came to the other games and she
didn't do so well um
so yeah it's a lot about emotions as
well in chess then
yes yeah definitely you can be emotion
as emotional as you want away from the
board but
yeah when the clock starts you have to
shut that off and
meanwhile we do see a continuation of
this modern defense this is all very
traditional stuff
um okay i'm not so sure about anish
giri's last move but
he is playing quickly and that's the
most important thing he doesn't want to
get below on the clock
let the nerves uh start to set in uh
when he only needs a draw to progress
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see what
uh the players will be thinking about
over the next few moves white
has an almost ideal setup white has
these two pawns in the middle of the
board
and if you look at the white pieces as
well they're perfectly centralized
controlling
all the important squares meanwhile
black
his strategy the reason we call it the
modern defense is because actually
uh until a few decades ago this type of
situation wasn't um so popular
um essentially black is playing with
these two bishops if you notice these
two bishops they're on the longest
possible diagonals
of the board that is why uh maximum
vascular graft decided to push forward
with this pawn he's hoping to
lengthen the diagonal of this bishop a
bit later on and anushka says no i'm
going to push forward
i'm going to support my center and
maintain
this real grip on the position if white
can keep these pawns intact
white is doing great if black can
somehow undermine them and explode the
position open especially the center
for these two bishops then uh black will
have
decent chances to at least um cause some
chaos a bit later on meanwhile i think
yeah anish giri he likes these types of
positions where
i mean he's a classical player where he
controls the space his pieces are on
good squares
and with white's last move pushing
forward he has clamped down black can no
longer advance this is a potential
weakness
which has been fixed by white's last
pawn move and uh yeah i think anishigiri
will be happier with the outcome of the
opening
than maxine bashley grav we do see a
trade of pawns in the center and
how simply is black going to fight
against these it's not obvious
he's trying he's challenging that pawn
santa with his own pawn
and now comes the big decision
this is like the kaya scenario here
where you have a situation a center that
is so beautiful what do you do
and anish just goes for the minimum
fuss option which is simply just to
capture in the center
if he wanted to play a little bit more
dynamically he might have pushed the
pawn forward
or maybe even let the tension remain but
as it is
he's like okay nope simple simple is
good yup simplicity
um is what's required in this game and
that's all he needs to do remember
anishgiri is make a draw
and he gets through to the semi-finals
that's why he played pawn takes pawn
clarifying the situation in the center
i'm slightly surprised by black's last
move i think he had other options at the
very least he should have just
recaptured
the pawn and keep more pieces on the
board exactly and uh i
completely agree with you david i keep
the tension on the board
and you can just see now there's one
extra
well one less piece to worry about and
when it comes to the end game
there are certain things that become
more and more important
and one thing that i see especially is
that black potentially has a very
weak pawn on the right on the left side
of the board
you can see it and that is super super
weak and i can see if that aneces
manages to
pile on the pressure on that pawn well
he's going to tie down
a bishop and the rook to the defense of
that pawn and this is just going to
allow
a niche yeah yeah
that one as well and i'm just thinking
that he's going to allow him the freedom
just to
you know connect everything with the
rooks yeah and i think all anishigiri
needs to do
um firstly just safety first i would
push a pawn here
to control the center to stop any night
jumps and then
next anishigiri he'll just centralize
his rooks and um as ivanka
mentions these two pawns are going to be
eternally weak
this pawn is going to tie down the black
queen and this pawn is going to tie down
the black bishop and maybe the black
rook as well
so black is playing without those pieces
worst of all though this piece
black's bishop is blocked in behind its
knight and it's blocked in behind
this pawn so this bishop has no future
at all
um all anishikiri needs to do is bring
his rooks across and maybe bring his
knight
into the black position and um if these
two things happen i think anishiri not
only is he actually winning
but um he will have no problem guiding
this one towards the draw if that's what
he wants
wow and the winner of this quarter final
looks like he's a niche gary right now
we'll face
wesley seoul in the semi-finals who
knocked out alireza varusia
and do you think now definitely it's
going to be anishikiri
um it's looking likely uh vashi legrav
um he will want to take this whole
opening back
he will want to uh maybe just go back
and rely
upon his uh exactly just look at the
board you know
he's already a pawn down anish has just
captured the pawn
and uh the only thing that can save
maxim now
is his strength and that is that maxime
is the ultimate trickster
look at maxine's face there he just
exhaled he raised his eyebrows he knows
he's completely lost already
yes um i wouldn't be surprised to see
maxine and vachegrav just resign any
moment now
already wow how can you even find a move
i dare you find a movie
um if we bring up the analysis board um
we can see that maximum is completely
stuck
um there we see anish giri step push it
forward maxime look at this
this is a pin here this bishop cannot
move because the rook behind it would
just be captured and lost
um this bishop has to be defended by
this rook and the queen you are totally
right okay let's bring the players back
uh maxine rashford just resigns wow he's
had enough
the position was hopeless pawn down and
a bad position it's
over anish geary not celebrating on
camera but he is ready now for
the semi-finals a devastating game here
too maximum vagina
a devastating day losing two games
here yeah i mean that last game was just
a bit of a nightmare unfortunately he
took some risks and they backfired very
quickly
and against his opponent in the
candidates tournament this is a
prestigious one as well
no definitely um but okay he was playing
different types of opening there was a
lot of ducking and diving going on and
ultimately he will be saving the best
for the candidates
that is the one but uh yeah definitely
not a great start there you know because
he's going to be annoyed with himself
because he especially that last game
that was just chancellors well anish
geary fantastic day for him and this
game seemed fantastic
take us through the excitement david
yeah i mean i think
um just showing the last few moves is
enough um to demonstrate anishigiri's
superiority even just the final position
i mean if you just look at black's
pieces this rook is out of the game this
bishop is pinned
this queen is tied down defending this
bishop black
i mean he's paralyzed completely
paralyzed the only active move he can
even
imagine is knight takes bishop but now
the key behind anisha's idea
um he would take with the pawn yes
accepting doubled pawns but more
importantly
opening up this rook um and if you look
at the teamwork here a bishop
and the queen behind it all ganging up
on this one-week square
black is just completely lost here and
the problem is in the final position
is um if maximum vascular graft try
something else
if he for example pushes a pawn white
will simply kick this knight away and
once it retreats bring the final piece
into the game
um yeah i mean positional masterpiece by
any skiry but
not a good day at the office for basha
ligroff but aneesh giri you know
how impressed are you with what he has
shown so far in this tournament ah super
impressed he was
incredible in the preliminaries i mean
he had one slip up
but he was so good and uh here against
uh
maxine vachelagraph he's been winning on
demand and he's shown
great opening repertoires and uh yeah
absolutely well deserved to go into the
semis yeah and against wesley so i mean
the winner of two tournaments so far in
the tour
who do you think is the favorite in that
one yeah we haven't seen wesley so too
much uh today but
it did look like a smooth victory over
feruzia um i think wesley so has to
start as the favorite just because of
his success in the tour so far but anish
as he mentioned earlier
um a few days ago he's never felt better
than he does
right now he's never played better than
he is playing right now um so
wesley's so small favorite but anish he
can do it
yeah some exciting semifinals definitely
coming up
by i mean yeah the four probably the
four strongest players right now
um especially at rapid chess yeah so who
has been
the most impressive to you so far then i
mean i think
yeah yesterday or the day before you
said magnus carlsen um but then i
mean not the i still think he had a good
day but
not the best day yeah maybe so who do
you think has been most impressive yeah
today definitely wasn't magnus's best he
admitted that in the interview
um but napoleon actually looking
confident powerful
and same for a niche yep and we are
right now joined by
powerful confident initially ready for
semi-finals congrats
anish thank you thank you thank you what
a great day for you do you agree
um probably well so the thing is the
following
um today was a win-win situation because
either i will start my
training session uh resume it basically
or
or continue the tournament but
non-situation is the following that no
matter how i play i'm
stuck for four more days right because
of the so
i think now i changed the plan and i'm
going to try and win this tournament
all right and how are you going to do
that against wesley so in the
semi-finals
it's the secondary thing the most
important announcement is that i've made
up my mind i'm going to try and win this
tournament ah sorry
that's all i have so far uh now when it
comes to
making this plan uh come true uh well
yeah that's that's
uh another thing but i haven't thought
about it yet all right well
uh and each uh i did ask you a few days
ago if you ever
sort of felt that you're playing better
chess than you are have been in 2021
uh i'm not going to ask you that again
today i mean your
your chess playing is fantastic so what
about your chest playing are you the
most happy about right now
well i mean there are of course uh as
with everyone
there are also definitely things going
wrong um well not today probably but uh
yesterday for example there have been
some terrible moves that i made just as
a very complicated game there
there is no perfection and the more we
learn about the
chess about the game about the different
computers chess engines
the more we realize how imperfect even
the best players are
you know the magnus carlsen himself is
like a thousand points one thousand kilo
points away
from uh the strongest computer uh so
even if you play uh tremendous chess
even if you are in great form still you
are so far from perfection there is so
much to strive for
so i wouldn't exaggerate my um you know
my uh quality of the games but
of course i am happy with the results so
far i think it's my
um this season it's my favorite uh
uh best results so far right i think
i've only been to the final in the
previous
season and this season i haven't made it
to the semis yet so that's uh
something i'm happy about and looking
forward wesley is a
great opponent i'm looking forward yeah
and wesley he has been the conqueror of
magnus carlson
in previous tour events um is that going
to be
i mean as well as your goal of winning
the tournament is that going to be one
of the inspirations to show magnus how
it's done
well i'm not magnus carlson i'm not even
close so
in that sense that wesley is magnus
slayer it's not my problem
i mean yeah i i've had
lots of games with wesley i know him for
a very long time
very long time i mean i spoken to him
the
the first time i played them we were
both kids and it was the question you
know
who was sort of the more uh who was the
bigger
a prodigy at the time i mean we were
like i don't know 13 14 or something he
was a year older and a
step ahead uh and then i've met him
later
i spoke to him when back when he was
still in philippines and you know he was
telling me
how he lives alone and um
later the story about him has been told
many times you know
and it's a sort of a sad part in his
life but at the time
the way he said it to me didn't sound so
bad he was saying you know i'm living
alone
i can watch movies whenever i want and i
was i was a teenager
listening to that i think yeah sure
sounds good but yeah obviously
eventually he
moved to states and like all that
happened but i know him for a very long
time i've played
with him since the beginning of times um
there is a very fun clip of mine also
when i was uh i don't know 13 or
something very embarrassing you can find
it uh you'll probably enjoy it
a good clip to show how i uh
how i beat him uh in the uh if i can say
tournament to b group i think
it's very embarrassing very embarrassing
i was still a child at the time but yeah
i know him for a long time so
uh it's not like you know um i mean he's
great but uh
you know the history is too long that
it's not relevant we just start from
scratch tomorrow
yeah anish earlier you earlier you
mentioned that you were
quitting your twitter creativity for the
semi-finals and now that you've
uh announced that you are going you have
a goal
to are you going to make my life more
difficult
and stop twitter no but you know these
um
these things like uh you hope some do
you say things like you know
sometimes you tell you maybe you know
your wife is saying like
you know i want this uh diamond drink
and you say well you know if uh
if this and that happens i'll give you
the diamond ring and you hope that never
happened that never happens right
this is also one of these things like i
was thinking like again i have to tweet
something you know
and uh all the same hashtags and the
same um
this picture and i was thinking like you
know let me
let me sort of use an excuse and say
that i'm saving my creativity for the
semi-finals hoping i'm not gonna get
there and i don't need to you know
now i have to think about it again it's
harder you know by this
these days to come up with a new tweet
rather than um
rather than come up with the opening
you're gonna play not to mention not to
mention
i have to still post uh a picture with
the air things device here
see it's nicely red now i'm gonna shine
red because the co2 is too much
uh so maybe you can screenshot this and
this will count as a picture or uh do i
still have to post one yeah i think
everything says
we'll be very happy with this yes no
it's great i mean it's fantastic i have
two or three devices
one during one of the preliminary days i
suddenly
shot you know i had this panic shot
usually i have panic during
games because of the plunders but this
time this thing went red
i look and there is like 1200 uh i don't
even the
unit of co2 yeah and 1200 you know it's
for me it's like really a lot it's
already like
so i'm already i started to have like a
panic attack because i feel like i'm
dying with that too much co2 you know
i can barely breathe hopefully i have
here my balcony so i open it
uh while the game is going on and i push
the door open
and slowly but i mean you know just too
much too much all this
measure all these devices measuring
everything i have you know i already
have like uh
ever since that we have this air things
thing i already have air purifier air
humidifier
i don't want to see my electricity bill
i mean all my sockets are plugged
i mean there are all kinds of plugs
everything is plugged in working on
everything
still the co2 is too high i mean
air quality not knowing what to tweet i
mean that's the definition of first
world problems
[Laughter]
all right aneesh um we hope the air
quality and i are feeling fresh
uh tomorrow for the semi-finals good
luck
thanks thanks for joining
i love having him here in a good mood
yes
so great to see him like that and i mean
um as we mentioned playing some of the
best chess of his life in the form of
his life
looking super happy i mean it's good
signs for the candidates tournament as
well next month
despite bad air quality anish kiri is
playing the chess of his life and being
in a great mood we're loving it now
the coach finals they're over so let's
take a look at the results
from uh we did only have one game going
to
round four so magnus carlsen he was the
winner of
both of the matches he won also
today with um one win in the first round
janupomniochi was able to beat hikaru
nakamura today they played a draw
yesterday
but napolita on fire today with two wins
in the two first rounds
and then wesley soul like magnus
crossland he won the first day
two fantastic wins today and he is
through to
um the semi-finals where he will face
anish geary
who had a fantastic day today and here
it is
these are the four players going through
to the semi-finals it's going to be
magnus carlsen and janna pognati
two players born in 1990 they've been
battling out their whole lives and so
is the story with wesley's own each
geary day two have been battling it out
their whole lives
or at least since they were like 10 11
years old
yeah i think i remember playing a
tournament with them and they were both
12 13 and yeah look at them today
no strangers to each other but i'll be
fighting tooth and nail to get to the
final all right
fantastic we're looking forward to that
and right now we are joined by our great
friend uh simon williams hi simon
hi there how you doing we're doing good
and just talking about that it's going
to be um sort of remembering childhood
tomorrow with
the pogniacci and magnus battling it out
since they were 10 and same with
anish and wesley yeah
one of one of the nice things about
chess um is that you you do meet people
that you
you basically share a friendship and
rivalry with uh for the rest of your
life
so uh i think that's the case with uh
all the pairings tomorrow these guys
met them when they were babies and
they're still fighting it out at the top
level now so it's a
it's a nice game that brings people
together and then makes them fight it
out to death on the board
so yeah it'll be interesting and i guess
simon it's hard to say that we have any
surprises in the semi-finals i mean
these four players
have played fantastic throughout the
tournament jana pony actually one bad
day
but other than that fantastic yeah i
mean
magnus has been very impressive he
wasn't so impressive today but uh
the thing is he's in a very good
position and it's quite hard to play
your
your top level chess when you're sort of
so close to the finishing line
i i was particularly impressed with yam
and the way he played
um i probably more impressed and happy
for him than he was
you know he he was uh not showing much
emotion
um i don't know if that's a sign for his
big game tomorrow
um and the other one of course aneesh is
uh gonna be up against it against wesley
so who's uh
performed incredibly well in all the
previous champions tour legs
all right well simon now i'm actually
very excited
for the learning point it's coming up
right now
right so um this was uh magnus carson
playing some brilliant defensive play
and to be an all-around chess bed be a
world champion big grand master
you have to be good at every area of the
game the opening
the middle game the ending tactics and
also defensive
play now it seemed like he was under
some
pressure the black pieces here because
if you look at white's pieces in the
position white's pieces are tremendously
well placed
the rook is on the open file and that's
where you want to rook because
rooks work in straight lines the bishop
is
very nicely placed it can dive in and
also the knight is in the center of the
board and one very important idea that
white has
is to bring the knight into f6 this dark
square giving check
to the black king so it kind of looks a
little bit iffy here for magnus but now
he plays
i think a brilliant move he plays his
pawn
from two squares forwards right next to
the king
and this allows the special move
which is called on pass on which means
capturing passing so now the white pawn
can take that pawn
and you might think oh no magnus carson
has forgotten about this rule
he's just lost the pawn what's he doing
but the point being
he can now move his king and white
doesn't have the same options he has
before
so the knight cannot come into that
square the bishop can't come into that
square
and he also in a couple of moves times
gets his rook
to the open file himself so if we just
have a look the rook now comes to that
square
and he didn't have this possibility
before so the rook
dives into the position he activates all
of his pieces and it only cost him one
pawn but i think this kind of move kind
of separates magnus
from a lot of the other strong players i
mean i would have never
have played f5 game the pawn up like
that and it it shows that even when
you're playing defensive chess
you have to take risks and uh he managed
to win this game in great style and i
think
because of this f5 move so was magnus
carlsen in great shape then for the
start of the day
it just sort of dipped a little bit yeah
maybe he did what like i think most of
us do you you get very confident you win
the game you kind of relax a little bit
you know you take a little breather
but i think a very important role in
chess because it's really intense it's
an intense game
and you don't have any opportunities to
make mistakes you've got to only relax
when you
finish the match off and shake your
opponent's hand i don't think there's
any other sport which is
as intense as chess in that way you you
just can't relax at all
maybe he did that slightly how hard is
that david
i'll ask you first um just yeah i mean
it's incredibly hard when you
i mean when you know what needs to be
done and you know you're so close
um i mean personally i always get super
nervous i choke at those critical
moments
and um it takes superhuman players like
magnus to
um to be able to deal with that so many
times every single tournament he's the
favorite and uh every single
single tournament he tends to perform it
says chess
one of the hardest sports to sort of
play on a result
um i think it's just one of the most
intense games or sports you can get
because i mean
even in like football you can sort of
let a goal in you can come fighting back
um in basketball you know loads of goals
are scored you can come fighting back
when when you're playing chess
if you play one slightly bad move at
this level you lose
and and it's game over so i i do think
it's uh
more pressurized um than any other kind
of activity
uh which you can see which makes it so
exciting as well as we see
and uh oh simon i just noticed are you
celebrating like ivanka today
saint patrick's day yeah a little bit
yeah yeah yeah i've i've got the
i've got the sort of green green jacket
on so happy st patrick's day to everyone
so yeah definitely happy saying it's
green i've just seen this
vancouver got a green topping i i've got
a green as well oh okay maybe i'm kind
of bored yeah
i promise it's green so do you also have
a little glass of something nice then
where we can i i might have a cheeky
cheeky beer just cheers i'll just sneak
that one so
uh maybe maybe just waiting there until
the end of the show so yeah
nice nice slider there so yeah fantastic
i think you deserve one today uh
simon and uh i'm looking forward now
also to seeing the answer to
uh the puzzle of the day i know you may
be a little bit tipsy now so
let's hope you can give us the answer i
i think i'm okay i'm gonna save the rest
of that for later so
well this was a quite an amazing point
in chess history um
now everyone has their breakthrough
events and
uh we had this breakthrough game for
rajaboff and rajabov's
unfortunately being knocked out the
competition but he's been one of the
leading players
throughout and uh he was here with the
black pieces
and he was only age 16. wow now his
opponent
this was from 2003 uh was none other
than
gary kasparov and gary kasparov was
world number one on rating he did just
lose the world championship match
to kramnik but he was still rated the
highest in the world and he was
dominating
every single event he played in he was
an absolute
monster at the chessboard but rajaboth
has gone into this position here with
the black pieces and he's a piece up
and this is unheard of i mean kasparov
was
very distraught he didn't want to lose
to some youngster
and now it's what does black do to
convert
his advantage into a win because even
though you're a piece up you've got to
try to get the best out of it you've got
to simplify it if you can
and make it as easy as possible so the
move that black now played
a very clever move was knight on d
to c5 and the idea of this move
is to simplify the position when your
material up
you often want to swap off pieces make
it as easy as possible
to convert the advantage this is a very
nice way of
converting an advantage and i think one
of the things that a lot of players
struggle with
is winning one positions but using this
little tactical idea
that knight really has to be taken
otherwise it's going to go straight
into this position in front of the white
king
and it has to be taken and it was taken
but
now after pawn takes knight here i think
you
just have rook d8 and this is what is
called a pin the bishop can now not move
because it'd be moving into check
and whatever happens black is going to
play rook takes bishop
check and he's simplified the position
he's made it
a lot easier to win and you can imagine
the frustration that gary kasparov had
here he was one of the most um
should we say expressive players ever i
mean if you think the guys playing here
are expressive
gary kasparov was an oscar-winning actor
and
he was extremely distressed to lose to a
little a little boy
shall we say but a breakthrough event
there and a breakthrough game for the
young
ratchet buff wow so this uh this was in
2003 i think you wrote simon so
that's right yeah so it was this game
for casparo and then a few months 2004
a draw against magnus carlsen yeah
he was struggling against youngsters i
think
yeah definitely all right well is it
time to put simon on the spot then with
the question of the iranka
yes simon okay so
well we know that you are a grand master
but
what what other skills do you have that
are grand master level
oh right okay i'm struggling to answer
these questions
um maybe grand master
having a real leprechaun
saint patrick's day real ginger beard
does that count
yes i think you know it's not fake i can
try pulling it off but it will stay
there
i can promise um i am i don't know i
guess
yeah i mean i i used to be quite a good
swimmer and things like that but nothing
i'm not exceptional at anything else i'd
say
not any sport or anything simon's very
good at gardening
are you oh gardening wait i used to yeah
i've got my green fingers i used to like
a little bit of gardening
you know getting my herbs out and uh
growing my herbs yeah
so growing herbs and beard i never knew
that about you
hey i'm a grandmaster gardener so well
you know yeah
[Music]
fantastic all right well simon it's
gonna be a very
uh fun day tomorrow with uh semifinals
so uh
take it easy today on slim patrick's day
yeah have a great
st patrick's day and rest of the show
thank you simon bye
all right so how will you usually
celebrate saint patrick's day in england
go to the pub yeah have some drinks with
your friends and
yeah just enjoy life and it's a
different story now
so what would you be doing right now
david if it wasn't coveted if it wasn't
champion's chest or
in your normal life in england actually
i've never celebrated some patrick's day
in
england i've only ever celebrated it
once and that was when i was in the u.s
in st
louis the home of chess and um yeah in
the us it's a big big thing
yeah it's a patrick's day fantastic all
right well we did give him
uh the question of the day ivanka the
beard was the answer and that's a good
one
we have some fun ones from the audience
yeah we asked what skills do you have
that you are grand master level at
and yes the answers came thick and fast
and
they were very funny lots of lovely
lovely pictures which we enjoyed
and here are a few that we particularly
enjoyed and uh
one from ilia teclique he says i am a
grandmaster level as saying
i'll get to these today but rarely do
now that one i can also challenge you
on grandmaster level up and uh one from
omar kit
who says i think i am a gm at eating my
mom's cakes before she finds out
so tasty doesn't have twitter
and a tweet from elias a bollander who
says it's not
easy being a parent at gm level while
simultaneously keeping up with today's
games
but i'm trying good job it is a good job
yeah
certainly and uh one from harry galcotti
he says
my sleeping skills is on grand master to
legend level i can sleep anywhere at any
time
i could even sleep again after having
eight hours of sleep lucky you
wow and he's just sat there on a table
and then we have not a entry from
victoria t
who says her skill is recycling used
hardware parts to make diy
chess sets wow but the winner of our
competition
is actually from peter ellick
he actually wins uh air things device
mini and he says
my gm skill is skiing i'd love to trade
david
he did a great job on his first lesson
yeah so congratulations peter
you are the lucky winner of our air
things mini
and uh someone will get in touch with
you asking for your details
and congratulations once again what a
fantastic skier yeah on that mountain
yeah that looks good
scary though that's a steep slope yeah
that's that seemed dangerous
all right well uh semi-finals coming up
tomorrow
who's the favorite to to win the magnus
carl's invitational now jamaica
you know i was really impressed by
magnus carlsen you know the way he saved
it at the end but you know i think
wesley ooh still wesley though yeah he's
a bit of a juggernaut
all right what's your verdict david i'm
gonna put my neck out and say anish giri
wow i've been so impressed by him form
of his life and
um i'm loving his enthusiasm for the
game all right well four fantastic chess
players do
remain in the magnus carlsen
invitational one of them will be the
winner
the first semi-finals will decide who
heads to the final
and they start tomorrow those um
semi-finals and that's going to be super
exciting so we will definitely be back
even though it's saint patrick's day and
these people want to
celebrate but we will be here tomorrow
and we hope you will
as well so see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you